[Music]
h
it's blurred out oh D B how about yeah
how about now
no oh no wait we're live Ren we're live
right now oh my goodness it's working
wow all right o sweet wow what's up
everyone yeah okay so guys look I
promise you there's going to be
technical
difficulties that's a guarantee okay um
apologies me and ren have have been at
it for the last hour like trying to do
this okay so bear with us my my lips I'm
going to sound like I'm dubbed the whole
time because my audio is being pulled
from Skype and it's just whatever it's
going to be awesome guys Ren what's up
dude thanks for doing this yeah dude I'm
glad to be here you do these every week
and you've been asking me to jump on for
like years at this point you're like hey
I want you to join my stream you're
telling me to join your streams years
ago not really I
mean I don't know I'm just
yeah you know you came into the office
and you were like
dude let's do it and I was like oh my
God I wasn't ready for
that I told you that
yesterday it was like Thursday night I
was like you know what I think I do want
to do this because we talked about it on
the podcast earlier this week yeah about
maybe jumping on this stream and I was
like I'm ready let's do it so um people
have been asking you to come down and
it's super freaking cool that we're
doing this right now we almost got 500
people in the chat and it's going to be
growing through out this so what are we
going to do what's our goal today what
what are we up to all right so my goal
is to create this uh looping animation
of a onewheel climbing a curb which is
something that I like doing on my
personal one wheeel and uh we did a
whole video about it last year on the
crew Channel I think Clint you were
actually out of town when we made that
video yeah uh but yeah is um basically
there's this uh maneuver you can do on a
one wheeel where you approach a curb at
the last moment you kind of like do a
tail scrape and then you kind of like
jump up the curb essentially and the and
the wheel climbs up it and my goal here
is to basically just animate that
digitally we have this awesome 3D model
of a onewheel pint that we got from late
night renders his name is Reed he
actually really cool Instagram you guys
check it out a lot of lot of cool of
anyway anyway he actually emailed me
this year like
year
like don't have to ask me twice yeah
yeah oh no oh no no
okay double audio all the way across the
sky test test all right we're in here we
go check check check my God there's so
many why is there audio though that's
weird so probably what's happening we're
good we're good yeah we're good we're
good oh it's good now okay great yeah
great man there's a lot of people in the
comments I've got I've got the comments
pulled up on my iPad here so like I can
like I said guys there's going to be
Tech difficulties I'm out of sync I know
that you know I recognize that there's
just too many factors going to this at
one time but hopefully um we're going to
be in c4d doing stuff and you're not
going to be looking at my lips you're
going to be looking at okay and then the
final now give me some levels
again again no more levels for you I am
never talking ever again okay I think
we're how dare you ask so I'm going to
be uh I'm going to be monit
monitoring these levels here cuz like I
said technical difficulties they're
going to happen but guys let's just get
into it
so um Ren final levels give me some
final levels here one two three four
five sweet yeah cool So the plan is I'm
I'm basically going to
um to texture the heck out of this thing
and I'm going to make it look super
photo real and then Ren is going to take
that and then he's going to basically uh
uh like animate the scene he's going to
hand animate the scene in c4d so we're
going to be working together on this um
and combine forces at the end so yeah
that's the plan I know I'm out of syn I
know it y'all don't have to tell me I
know these things okay yeah trying to
get these double uh like I'm streaming
to Clint and Clint is streaming what I'm
streaming to him to you guys so this is
a weird setup we've not tried before so
apologies wait it's still getting double
audio that no it's not though it's
not wait really guys if we're getting
double audio right now let me know but
if not give me some thumbs
UPS also thank you everybody for the
super chats I appreciate you
guys all right wait someone's saying we
stole this idea from one whee Loop
posted on Reddit I don't even know what
you're talking about so one whe
everyone's done one whe Loops it's fine
know right um nbv thank you for the
Super Chat I appreciate you um he wishes
you what does he say Ren please convince
some of the other Corridor folks to
learn Houdini I dream of a a future
where Corridor level tips and tutorials
um for that exist I mean we'll see uh
I'm I'm someone's got to start in in and
I decided I'll just try to learn Houdini
um and if it goes well maybe others will
join in after that I mean that's what
Sam did Sam jumped into Unreal Engine
for like a year by himself before other
people really started joing although you
you you started up pretty early on Clint
yeah it's it's good stuff um and uh yo
PHP thank you for the Super Chat I see
you man
freaking awesome we're going to get a
nice a nice little dinner me and ren
both the two of
us all right so Ren I'm going to I'm
going to start texturing this thing in
My Scene here um and then uh you know I
guess so to be clear the thing does
already have textures the the guy I Reed
he uh he did texture it but he made it
like kind of like product worthy you
know where it's like like a product shot
it's all clean it's all nice so you're
going to basically just just modify
these textures and make them like used
here I'm going to I'll show you the I
don't know if it'll be blurry or not and
I'm I'm afraid of changing anything in
case it messes up the string so I don't
know if this is going to be that visible
but here's my V1 and it's like super
super scratched up it's a little blurry
let me get my pint I'll be right
back yeah why blurry why it
blurry
whatever anyway
yeah I I now regret turning on the the
blur filter and now I'm afraid of
turning it off all right so we
got this
guy yeah that's the the corridor pint
there and it's also scratched up so my
goal is to get it looking like that get
it looking
nice
wait
so I'm going scratch this thing up and
ren you're going to hand animate this
thing going up a curb yeah yeah yeah
sweet all right so let's get to it man
all righty
uh okay animation something I'm not
particularly uh confident in uh but I
will get started let's see okay I'm
going to save this as a new file so Ren
let me know um I'm going to be on your
screen right now um okay and then switch
over to me when I feel like I got
something to show and we'll just go back
and forth and I'll I'll let you know
when I'm on you or when I'm switching
off of
you all right I now
have okay let's check out this hierarchy
here
um got some
lights board here
got the
engine I think technically it's a motor
but what's your plan like what do you
want to
do so okay
roughly my plan is that I will first
probably just start by modeling a curb
of some sort oh my God hold up this this
one wheel is massive
uhoh where's
the
look at this what if what if I like flew
a drone over a parking lot and then like
tracked in like a giant one wheeel in
the in a car spot you know like a
parking spot oh that's pretty
hilarious kind of funny let's get the
scale right though because I'm going to
have to my textures are going to be
based off of our our our scale so let's
maybe um scale this down until it's
like if I'm holding
shift
20% okay I'm going to try
15%
so5 on the scale
yeah that's about right that's about
right it's close
enough so it's just above the knees yeah
so I have I I selected the onewheel null
object and set it to 15 for scale you
see that
there um
yeah
sweet all right so plane
here my modeling skills are very very
rudimentary um oh it's cool so we're
mine I I tried streaming how to uh how a
texture a car and it was rough it was
rough
so that's a good tip for everybody is to
get your scale right you want to get
your scale right because then it all all
your stuff is kind of based off of the
scale so that helps out a
lot right I'm making a a 4x3 plane here
so I'm going to hit C locking that in so
now
two
thenit how high is a curb I'm just going
to make this
a 25 cm curb dang it you got to make
sure it can Su Bonk up it you know you
got to make sure it can get up
it yeah I dude I I tried to Bonk up a
really really big curb yesterday and
totally broke my one wheel yeah I saw
that I mean I was literally there I
saw oh yeah you were there that was you
yeah okay
okay um Joon thanks for the Super Chat
man I appreciate you everybody it does
help it's very helpful you know a lot
goes into this kind of stuff um it's
very stressful especially setting up all
the text stuff in the beginning God I
got to get that figured out you know I
got to get all that stuff worked out but
in time you know in time I'm just glad
we're doing this
together all
right and if you're feeling Ren if
you're feeling like you want to switch
over to my screen just let me know and
I'll switch over
okay I'm gonna
also Sid thank you thank you for the
Super Chat he says I can't wait for the
body solver plugin for c4d to come out
does ren have any more information on
that I don't know what that is I have no
more information on that what is the
it's just some dude on Twitter uh who
like tagged me in something and uh has
like I guess he's making a plugin called
body solver for C for
D what does it
do I'm not entirely sure to be honest
it's just those two words exist kind of
like a it's kind of like a rag doll
thing
uhhuh that's
cool all right I'm going to switch over
to me real quick and give out give a
little info
here so guys um once again apologies for
the out of sync audio here but look you
know you just listen and close your eyes
and and you also watch the screen too
you know we're going to learn a lot so
here's what I'm going to do I want to
really scratch up these rails on the
side here so I'm going to do that with a
mixed material and octane basically you
have your base material which is you
know across this entire one wheeel let's
see if I can find
it here we go here's our
textures so this is wrapped across the
entire one wheel
right now what I want to do is make a
chrome material that can go underneath
that so the Chrome material is going to
go underneath and then I'm going to
reveal that Chrome material with a
surface imperfection texture a number of
them um yeah so it's actually quite
simple but it just takes time to tweak
and get right I think I'm I'm going to
scratch up the side here I'm going to
change out these screws for some nice
metallic screws and really scratch these
things up um
and then I'll start scratching up the
actual plastic and I want to do a pass
on the on the tire too have it have a
bunch of rocks and stuff in it make it
look all used and gross same for the
handle I'm just going to scratch
everything up and make everything look
really used I'm going to add dirt to the
inside of this wheel um I'm going to add
dirt and scratches that's basically what
I'm going for so I'll start with this
little scratch pass
here got to get those surface
imperfections they're very important
so with the mixed material I'll drop in
this uh this glossy material that I made
I set the index to one and then I will
drop in I want to make sure I'm using
the right texture so this is referencing
this texture here this low plastic one
and I'll just drop that into the mix
material and I'll put the mix material
on the standing board and it's going
between these two materials with a float
texture and you guys know this if you've
been hanging out for a
while um you know that a float texture
by default mixes between these two
textures um with a value of 0. five if I
go to one side it's one texture if I go
to one it's the other texture by default
it's right in the middle we don't want
to do it that way we want to do it with
a surface imperfection texture so I'll
add an image texture and I'll navigate
to one of my Surface imper Perfections
that I made late last year let's
see Clint yeah I just realized I I
totally stopped working and I was just
watching you on the stream are you
serious yeah I've just been staring at
your your screen this whole time I was
like dude Ren's quiet like I wonder
what's going on that's
hilarious um so yeah let's find this uh
let's find this texture boom I'll go
with a 4K texture because we know we
want it to be kind of close up and and
detailed we'll start with this basic
one and by default you can see it's
revealing the the scratched Chrome or
the the you know it's revealing that
Chrome texture underneath this clean
texture here but it's a little big I
want to be able to control it so let's
go ahead and give it a projection
node and we'll set that to box and
that's going to wrap it evenly
around uh our model here and then I also
want to give it a transform because it's
too small so I think we can set it to
like
10 maybe it's too big
0.1
0.01 there it is yeah it's way too big
.1 and we can crunch the gamma to like
four so it kind of tightens up around
those scratches maybe if you set it to
eight you can see that it like it's like
the equivalent of um you know of
crunching down your
levels and if you do the opposite it's
going to show more of those
scratches so we set our gamma to four
and scale it up
0.0
o5 how many how many O's do we want o
5 sweet and then you can mix these
together with a a mix
node this mix node can mix together
different scratch textures so let's say
that one's looking good and I want to
bust out another one so maybe we can
control drag to duplicate this setup
that we
have
and let's pipe that into the amount so
we can see what we're
doing and we'll I'll switch it out for
another one of my scratch
textures it's another subtle one and
maybe we can take the gamma of this one
to one to have more of the scratches
come through and we can scale it down
.001
Ren what do you think your camera angle
is going to be like this like kind of
wide I haven't decided yet it can be uh
ideally it's not super wide so we can
actually like see the detail that'd be
cool yeah agreed but the the one whe is
going to be full frame probably
right fullish frame cool all right sweet
Christian thanks for the Super Chat dude
much
appreciated shout out to Christian y he
always he says um he's he gave you some
bcha money
actually
yeah all right I think the tire is not
uniform
really holy crap I just realized I'm
trying to figure out so I'm rotating the
one wheel end over end
if you want to switch back to my screen
real quick I can show people
got
um like yeah you're on so here here's
the ground right here this little blue
line and if I rotate it the tire
like makes contact and kind of goes away
a little bit so here it's there's like a
little bit of a gap but if I rotate 90°
it's now like intersecting the ground
rotate another like 90 and it's up in
the air again so I was trying to figure
out if maybe my like Center Point was
off but I think the tire is actually a
little
wider it's so tiny though like it's
it'll probably be not too
noticeable sure probably
not but I'm G to try
to all right so I'm on You Ren if you
want to just like just a little bit of
that walk them through what you got
going on I'll keep working on this
texture all good cool so right now I'm
basically just trying to
start figuring out basically laying the
groundwork for this animation so I'm in
my right side view right now as opposed
to uh like this perspective View and I'm
just going to go through and start
laying some key frames for some motion
so yeah maybe on
frame frame zero it's way over here and
I will put my coordinates and just hit
my
rotation at
[Music]
90 set
this how high off the ground am I 17.8
maybe a little bit of Gap 1.5 that's a
little
less split the difference
sure uh all right now setting key
frames for frame zero
oh snap you're moving it you're like
going to
town are you rotating the wheel or are
you like moving it towards the
curb I'm just going to block out the
main motion of the board I think the
tire rotation will be one of the last
things I animate
um and I'm not exactly sure how to do
that I might just not how to do it but
what I'll do I don't know if I can maybe
link up some sort of system so that it
actually rotates
according to the the linear motion of it
yeah remember uh doing something like
that back in on in my 3ds Max days but
I'm not sure if I know how to do that in
cinema so I might just do it manually
but the tire spinning is not super
important so I want 100 frames forward
and I'm going to go to right here oh man
this is a tall curb just a dis a tall
curve I'm going to set
my Z key frame so
now and now
here we like just
shy know what I will
just oh
oh interesting okay so I actually have
to back this up because you want to like
scrape the tail right basically and pop
it right on yeah so you can kind of see
where this is also I'm hoping this will
be a interesting exercise for people
hoping to learn how to do the curb nudge
uh oh nice all all like 0.1% of you
guys
uh because you'll get a better glimpse
of what I'm doing here so technically
right here is where I need to have that
so yeah for those of you guys who don't
know it's actually possible to go up
curbs with this thing Ren does it all
the time and he's basically doing a 3D
version of it right
now so now I have to get this up a
little bit further so I'll probably make
contact with the tire
here rotate
that and push
up okay that's a little too
far what the
difference something like
[Music]
that there we
go okay now let's set those key
frames dude it's so crazy that uh wait
what
okay it it's flying through the air now
I I forgot to add a key frame
somewhere okay frame 100 here got to set
this back to the ground level whatever
the heck that frame
was
okay dude remember remember when got me
uh into octane
Ren yeah
that was that was a long time
ago it was a while ago I can't remember
no yeah that's right cuz you got in the
CD first and I we did the that that Nerf
Battle Royale or the foam foam fighter
foam what was that one video we did up
in like freaking yose and you're making
all those yeah foam fortnite and you're
making all those little uh like noodle
walls and rendering them with motion
blur using the default
renderer it's taking 128 Hours to render
this shot I'm like what you're like yeah
it's taking it's taking 25 minutes per
frame to render I'm like it would take 5
seconds in octane yeah and I didn't
believe you I was like dude no I have to
learn how to use the program like by
default you know like I I can't I can't
start adding all these plugins if I
don't learn the the default program and
you're like dude trust me you got to
switch to Octane and I'm like no I'm not
going to do it and I just like it was so
dumb I should have just
switched oh man dude this I'm already
realizing this is going to be a bigger
animation challenge than I anticipated
but what's new in life yeah same for me
the um the scratches are going to be
really
intense good I mean I want this thing to
be lived in oh it's going to be lived in
is that a phrase and Liv on well that's
the thing like everyone buys their one
wheel and it's all you know super shiny
and fancy when they get it but pretty
quickly it gets scuffed up and I like a
scuffed up one wheeel it means it's
being used y if a one whe is like fresh
looking M I want to see them scratches I
want to see them that abuse one wheels
are meant to be abused it's true mine
got ran over by a
car a truck dude it got run over by a
truck a freaking pickup truck and you
almost died I can never forget it dud
you should you should tell that
story should I all right yeah so one day
we're all heading out to lunch you know
we all roll out on our on our one Wheels
we're going down the street cross
through this big intersection we're
going along we're on the and we crossed
over to the other side of the road so
now we're like riding on the shoulder of
the road in oncoming traffic it's it's a
it's a it's a regular you know Road two
lanes one going each Direction but we're
on the other side cuz there's like a bit
of a shoulder there like for parking
spots you know
but there's no cars anyway we're rolling
along and Clint looks back at me for
something cuz you know traffic he looks
back at me at the perfect moment where
he hit what we call a ghost bump and
basically a ghost bump is a bump that
you can't see it jumps out of nowhere
and yells Boo and they're terrifying
they will end your life they and it
almost ended
mine yeah cuz anytime you hit a bump on
a one wheel it's it's it's hard because
you only have that single point of
contact with the ground you know on a
bicycle it's a little easy because you
have two points of contact you hit a
bump your front wheel goes up but your
back wheel is still like okay and then
your back wheel hits it after your front
wheel's down the ground again so it's
like where's a one wheel you hit it and
your entire board goes up into the air
uh if you're not prepared for it if you
are prepared for it it's not that big of
a deal you can navigate it you know bend
your knees and absorb the shock of it
but if you're not it will throw you off
the board like it did to Clint that day
so he turned around and looked at me
just as this truck is is basically about
to pass him he hits this bunk and starts
falling backwards towards this truck
going I don't know 20 mph it's coming
it's coming towards me like head
on yeah and he stumbles and fortunately
doesn't stumble out into the road and
goes down literally a foot away from the
tires of this truck but his one wheel
kept going and actually slid underneath
the back tire of the pickup truck and
the whole back of the pickup truck
launched into the air as it jumped over
the one wheel like it literally like
went over the rear like foot pad where
the battery is the one wheel and like
actually caught a little bit of air and
the one wheel was totally fine dude it
it ripped off your Fender I think though
didn't it it did yeah it was just really
sketch cuz
like yeah like if if it wasn't for that
truck like that truck could have been
any other car and it would have
destroyed the under side of the car it
would have total any other car it would
have killed someone on a motorcycle it
would have like if you were in a smart
car maybe you would have blown up you
know but like the fact that it was this
lifted
truck that was the only vehicle that
could have with stod a one wheeel going
underneath it because it only touched
the tire it didn't touch the axle it
didn't touch the underside of the car
and dude we got so lucky that that truck
went boom it
flew he did stop to like make sure
you're okay which is cool yeah he did
that was
nice that was very nice um Andre it's
your first time joining that's awesome
we Natalie's also
here Y what up n yo uh yeah apologies
guys I'm out of sync this is old news um
I I promise we're going to have
technical difficulties I promise but I
promise that you will also learn
something too
so yeah it's it's a good time thanks for
uh thanks for doing this
Ren yeah no I'm excited for it we've
been we've been talking about doing this
forever at this point mhm and I'm like
enough talk make it reality let's do
it all right so I'm texturing the heck
out of this thing I'm trying to just
isolate where the the material goes here
I'm just trying to keep it
isolated
right I'm I'm pretty
much a little further dude we got 666
people in the chat yo what's up guys
right now 676 it's it's climbing that's
freaking awesome thanks guys for
joining all right so I'm trying to
basically uh grunge up this one wheel
and ren is is animating the one wheel
and then we'll combine forces at the end
here for the
ultimate the ultimate one
wheel the ultimate animation because at
the end of day we're making an
animation right okay so I think I got my
I think I got a rudimentary animation
down all right switching over to you
here switch
back all right what you
got okay let's
see so I'm still ins side view right
here just got it going tail slide into
the
curb climb up
it oh
nice so I'm just going to play
it all right super awful still but it's
the basic architecture of a curb nudge
now I have to go through and actually
get like the curves right the ACT make
sure there's no clipping make sure the
actual like timing of everything kind of
works but these are like the big sort of
like points you got the tail drag
approaching the curb and as you uh as
the front foot pad of the board hits the
curb it actually starts raising the
whole board off the ground so the
technically right when you're hitting
the curb the the tire itself might be
upwards of like an inch or two off the
ground uh and you just kind of use that
momentum to just kind of like pop up so
you're basically reducing all of your
weight on the rear foot pad and all of
your weight goes to the front foot pad
and that causes it to tilt down and then
the tire actually climbs up the curb as
you're doing that and so the front still
stays on the ground tire is climbing up
cuz your right foot is reducing all your
weight off of it and then then you climb
it and then you kind of reenter your
weight and usually kind of pendulum
swings back the other way a little bit
and then
you uh you got to give it some air too
like a little air when it pops
up I
mean like right there considered doing
that well you don't get air on on an
actual curb nudge you can and I think
this is a little too big to Bonk it'd be
sweet though I
mean yeah I'm I'm trying to make this as
like physically accurate as possible to
how the mechanics of a onewheel thing
works as opposed to just like cool cool
yeah I got you the thing um one let me
let me uh let me tell you about this
quick tip real quick so if you hit alt V
on your keyboard Ren alt alt V yeah and
then go to
wait did that work V yeah and then go to
uh
HUD HUD yeah and then there should be a
frames per second check
box why would I want that cuz then you
can see if your animation is playing in
real
time so when you play it if you're
getting more than 30 FPS then it's
playing in real time dude I was getting
240 FPS okay you're good yeah you're set
sometimes it'll chug if it's like you
got too much much stuff going on if it
does you see that little film strip
button on the bottom right um right
above your coordinates your world
coordinates on the bottom right if you
hold the film yeah hold that down and
then uncheck all
frames and then it'll actually play to
your viewport frame
rate okay it's GNA look exactly the same
for you though because you already
playing at 240 frames but if it gets
chuggy that'll that'll be like a nice
little like a
chuggy a way to see all your
stuff I got you okay so now I got to
start adding in some more middle key
frames here so this
guy dude animation is so
hard
yeah I'm just I'm just like it's like
it's like when you do uh key frames on
on rotoscoping you set your first and
last and then you go in you start
getting more and more precise in the
middle totally
um
so yeah this is It's Going rough
dude all right I'm G switch over check
the switch over to me
here okay um basically what I'm trying
to do is connect my
scratch texture to the bump texture so
the scratches actually look like they're
being like pushed into the one
wheel um oh nice nice nice Yeah so
basically I'm using this scratch texture
to to differentiate between these two
textures a like a base gray and the
actual one wheel texture the one whe
texture is like it has the text on it
has the Pint logo here this gray texture
is the lighter gray that you're seeing
through the scratches so I think the
best way to see this is like to probably
get the
the
sunlight in the right direction that way
I can actually get some shadow on the
bump let's see if I
can it doesn't look like it's doing it
I'm wonder if I need a pipe oh dude we
got Daffy in the chat Y what up dude oh
really dude Daffy what's up heck
yeah Daffy is uh quite the professional
quite quite the man indeed um he does a
lot of things I don't even know like
what's the proper intro for
Daffy uh my my uh what do you call it uh
I feel like he's a a cryptoart
sherpa yeah like among other does that
make sense yeah certainly you know he's
like he's helping he's helping people
um you know answer questions a lot of
questions about crypto art which is
freaking awesome he's he's helped me out
a lot he's helped both of us out a lot
it's a very cool space that I am very
excited to get into and ren as
well yeah oh my goodness the H wait okay
I am tired of my default key frames
going to B A curves I need them to be
linear dude hit control d right now
control D because I remember I saw Chad
do this from Grace SK gorilla he did it
in a tutorial where he set his default
key key interpolation set it to linear
up top first drop
down this one first drop down set it's a
linear
interpolation that just do it yeah
interpolation linear cool so now all
your frames are linear save yep I'm
going do that right now
too so if you want now I have to go yeah
save it as your default scene that way
it'll always be linear every time you
start Cinema yeah I'll have to do that
next
time all
right
all right let me know when you want me
to switch back to you I'm still working
on trying to get this bump look
here so I have an animation here it's
just like the timing is awful here I'll
go to
you yeah so here's uh here's the
animation so
far I spent too much time trying to like
get get the specifics of the key frames
that I don't have their their timing set
up at
all got you okay yeah I that's I guess
just like sliding around key frames
until it until it feels right I guess
yeah pretty
much yeah because right now it's like it
approaches the curb and then stops and
then goes up and then continues whereas
in reality it's a very fluid
motion
yeah nothing like jumping in on a on the
first stream doing something that I have
very little confidence
in it's cool we'll figure it out dude
yeah okay I think I'm actually going to
try to delete some of these key frames
and instead try to do the motion with
curves so shift F3 will bring up my key
frame a dope sheet dope sheet a very how
do I get the uh a there we go there we
go
dude everyone's like you got this Ren
you got this thanks guys I appreciate it
we got 700 people up in here right now
thank you everybody 700 700 we got 700
people
yeah
measle beer oh my God wait Jan dude
Jan's up in here wait Jan's in here yeah
Jan what up Jan dude that's awesome dude
I I literally just dropped a reference
to Jan and without even knowing that
he's here yeah um do you want to tell
the beers story oh my goodness yeah sure
so what was this like three years ago at
this point this would have
been gosh February or March 2018 there
is a rocket launch from SpaceX out of
Vandenburg uh Air Force Base which is
like a couple hundred miles from here
maybe less than but it's on the coast up
north west of us and so they were going
to have a launch at like 7 in the
morning and I was like all right guys at
the time it was the four boards men it
was me Jan Clint and Cliff and I I sent
a message out because this is back when
it was basically just us we were the
only ones with one wheels and uh within
our friend group and I was like guys
there's a rocket launch and I think we
might be able to see it from the top of
this uh Mountain down the street from us
so it's it's a ride that we do all the
time and so we ended up getting up at
like 5: in the morning to go climb this
mountain so that we can see a rocket
launch at dawn it was sick dud top of a
mountain it was like a week wasn't it a
weekday too it was a Friday morning
that's awesome and so so we get up there
and uh we we take our first break of the
day I think we had to charge too we all
brought our little batteries to charge
yeah and uh cuz this is before we had
the XRS we were all running freaking v1s
and so we get up to the A an Overlook
and it's still dark like the sun hasn't
quite risen yet and and Jan's like
anyone want a beer and freaking Ren Ren
it blew Ren's mind he couldn't fathom
beers before noon and like I mean
granted all of us were like Jan Before
Sunrise Before Sunrise Before Sunrise
and like of course it's Jan so it's like
yeah of course I brought beers but
everyone else was like what and ren
vocalized it and he was just like beers
and dude we freaking lost it it was so
funny we all looked back we're like Ren
what did you just
say well I remember being like beers
what like just exploding and then I look
over and Clint and Cliff were just like
looking at each other
giggling I'm like what are you giggling
about and it was like the same
intonation when when we called your clap
measly and you like
measly you just said it in the measi
voice dude it's so
funny measly measly oh boy okay so my uh
rotation here I'm only rotating one axis
right now and I'm going to keep
that
uh X position I have no key frames on X
got some key frames on y
and I make this bigger Okay cool so this
way I'm going to maximize this this way
no uhoh uh oh what
happened what happened octane
crashed oh no God oh
no that means you got to restart your
program yeah dude what if you had to
restart your computer oh man no there's
no
way that that has yet to be a thing
that's good yo Deon Williams up in the
chat you know Devon right Ren oh I know
Devon yeah wasn't he the dude who got
like shot in the knee by an arrow yes
like 10 years ago that was Devon that
was Devon he was no I I know Devon from
more recent times too like when he
visited and what not yeah he was the guy
who helped out on the Matrix The Matrix
shoot and then turned into a lobster
the next day dude straight up L wait
Devon do you still have all that hair of
course he has all that hair dude I feel
like when Devon cuts off his afro he
will be a different person like
physically mentally and emotionally a
different person he will weigh one one
whee
less that sounds about
right and then we got J boss up in here
too dude joke School uh president in the
house this this is a good little group
of people we got up in here this is
awesome all right I'm just reconnecting
textures what what are you doing Ren
what's going on in your
world I'm trying to be less lightheaded
Li headed had too much coffee in my
system
oh well that's not
good it's it's the definition of
perfection I live for
no I'm joking I'm joking okay so uh
right now oops I'm going do um hopefully
this is working is this still working
yeah you're on yeah it it it there's a
little delay in it but as soon as I
switch over to you you're you're good to
go so I've got my dope sheet pulled up
and I'm tempted to delete all these key
frames in the middle here and try to
replicate that motion just using curves
and fewer key
frames it's not a bad I
mean
so um yo shout outs to Paul for the
Super Chat man um I'm glad you like to
work in the
personalities U anytime and Andre also
he says the the c4d also have bump node
like blender um maybe a bump a bump node
but a bump Channel definitely has a bump
channel so Ren what do you think the
benefit is between like having a ton of
key frames versus like fewer key
frames
you uh so having more key frames you end
up with this sort of
artifacting uh this motion artifact that
I don't even know how to describe it's
basically just like very stair Steppy
you know and you want to have smooth
motion and the more key frames you have
the less smooth it'll be so you want to
try to replicate the sort of curve that
a lot of key frames will give you but if
you just you can create curves and
bezier curves and whatnot using just
single key frames here uh so if I
actually but I don't specifically know
how to do this so if I set this to what
like spline I can edit the curve uh but
I only have one okay how do I get select
how do I get the bezier curve on select
all of them I don't want I don't want to
do it I'm doing this one at a time so I
just selected this one key frame here
but I only have the one handle on the
one side how do I get it on both sides I
think you need it on the the key frame
to the left you have to make the left
really yeah I think
so like I'm not the best with animation
either but give that one and turn that
yep yeah that worked that worked and
then you just like okay bring the handle
down so that way you get uh as it comes
rolling in it smoothly
goes and this one actually I want it to
be very sharp okay now how do
I how do I only control one spline
control I
think no that that just uh scales it in
and out I shift and ALT try those ones
shift and Al or no no like sweet that
was it that was it that was it was it
shift and ALT or just
shift shift and ALT wow I totally
guessed I meant to do them individually
but
hey it
works yeah cuz I want this to be more of
a slam so I want this to be a sharp
motion where it goes actually you know
what I'm G to have it ping pong a little
bit I'll have this go up I'll have that
go up so it's
like okay now I needed to actually hit
another key frame
here
this
getting okay I'm G to actually delete
that
one oh snap dude if this is a true tip
then it's blowing my mind um Co com
comata thank you for the Super Chat and
the sweet tip he says when Cinema
crashes you can save the project just
press left shift right shift and delete
there's no
way what that's the
trolliest dude no way what
what wait okay so if Cinema crashes and
it's like Frozen and you can't get it to
respond you hold both shifts and then
hit delete apparently it works I don't
want to try it that's but it doesn't
always work I'm not it doesn't always
works yeah what is
that yeah it's like alt f4 dude you
can't get me with that that's too old
also Casey and Cliff are up in here
right now yo what up Casey yo Cliff wait
where's Cliff I just told the beer story
did did Cliff hear the beer story yeah
bet you I maybe it's right he's right
under the Super Chat yeah he's like
w I literally just told the story about
when we went up to the top of a mountain
to watch a rocket launch and I was blown
away by Jan pulling out beers to drink
before sunrise
that was awesome so ridiculous
uh oh boy dude animation is hard dude
yeah so is streaming dude freaking
streaming is is
uh very like takes a lot of your brain
power you know you're like trying to
focus and you're trying to entertain but
you're you're trying to focus on the
thing and then you find out you're being
quiet the whole time and then you got to
oh I got to say something it's a lot
yeah it's a
lot oh I dude I just realized Devon's uh
profile pick is literally his afro yep
there's a drawing actually I did of him
a bucket of beers I see you Casey yo
Chase is up in here
too we got Chase up in
here editing all those freaking VFX
artist React videos killing it oh yo
what up Chase yo what up Chase got the
crew oh also uh shout out to Daniel it's
his birthday today he edits the crew
cuts on the website yeah happy birthday
Dan that man works so hard oh yeah I got
to get back to work I'm just like
watching the
chat okay I'm G switch over to me here
um sounds good guys I got some like
light scratching that I'm kind of happy
with here um on the side of the one
wheel and now it's time to add the
deeper scratches that reveal the Chrome
texture
so on the one wheel let me see if I can
go full screen
here I know I'm out of sink so bear with
me but on the one wheel there
are little scratches that reveal the
Chrome texture only on the
edges right so I want to get that
down that's next dude the Pint has been
beat up
it has like this the screws came loose
on the rear bumper and so I had to Gaff
tape it down that's why there's Gaff
tape there jeez dude that's
rough um let's see let's get this plane
out of here visibility be
gone be gone okay so dirt nodes do these
basically this is how this works so I'm
going to take this mix material that I
made for the side panel okay
and I want to scratch it up so what I
need to do is make another mixed
material and I'm going to put this mixed
material in it I'm also going to put
that steel um that glossy texture with
the index set to one it looks like a
chrome ball just has a little bit of
roughness on it I'm going to combine
those two and I'm going to put that
on technically I'll put that in
place of this texture here
bam
now I want to be able to tell this
chrome material to only be on the
edges of the model here so once my
computer is done
crashing um I will show you guys how to
do
that yeah the audio is out of syn it's
all good there there's going to be some
some technical
difficulties that's just the way and
it's just me too Ren Ren's all in
sync dang dude I'm I'm I'm crashing
again
Ren all right left shift all right I'm
doing it I'm trying it left shift right
shift
delete I don't know nothing
happened I it happened I don't know
oh man oh try to delete system 32 yeah
that'll definitely
work oh God shift F4 what does shift F4
do yo David David Turk just donated five
bucks and said uh asked if we've used
octane X on Mac OS Catalina so just to
quickly answer that question no haven't
tried it we don't use Macs yeah we're on
PC I've never used a Mac
same
same um I'm switching to You Ren because
no one wants to watch me crash
here oh what a
shame oh god dude my animation is awful
it's so bad see so bad see
it
blink hey that's not bad at the top
though the way it like evens out are you
going to have it keep going cuz you want
to you want to be ble to Loop all these
over right exactly yeah so uh I'm going
to have to figure out some sort of way
to basically Loop these key
frames once I but right now I'm going to
focus on getting the animation working
and then I'll figure then I'll worry
about figuring out how to actually like
duplicate these key frames so that I can
have it like
Loop um yo that tip it kind of
worked it did yeah like I don't know I I
honestly don't know how it worked or if
it really did work but like this is
where I left off that's
weird that's awesome yeah I'm going to
try that next time for
sure dude it was oh man it's so rough I
was working on uh that I was I was at
the studio really late this is like
almost midnight
Friday before the up video release and I
was at the studio trying to do that one
shot with the the house in the in the
next to the windmill and then the statue
of Liberty yes yeah I remember that I
did a whole bunch of
stuff and then it crashed on me oh no
and I was like oh that sucks uh and I
boot it back up and
realize I didn't have autosave turned on
at all dude and I lost about an hour and
a half of work that is so rough because
I guess I just forgot to stop saving and
you know I know better I definitely know
better and I'm usually pretty good about
saving frequently but it was just that
one time where I forgot to do it and
then it crashed on me and I lost all the
work and it sucked but of course because
I had to redo the work it ended up being
better that's the Andrew price thing
right where he's like yeah you do it
over again like he's crazy he's crazy
cuz he literally he does that like did
you watch his Cabin in the Woods um
breakdown like his 20-minute breakdown
on
that
no not so
basically he walks you guys through how
to how he did his cabin right and then
he's like yeah I I spent two weeks like
getting this scene all nice and then I
deleted it and then I did it over yeah
and he was like but his reasoning was
because like I may have like toggled
something I didn't mean to toggle um and
you know and a bunch of other reasons
and he yeah he just redid it in like a
day and it was cleaner and it was nicer
and like it was a bit more organized and
I was like man that's crazy
dude so yeah if you if you mess up and
you lose all your work it'll be all
right because you'll do it again much
faster
Daniel thanks for the Super Chat
appreciate
you man we got a lot of people
commenting this is cool I should do this
more
frequently what the the live stream yeah
oh yeah you should it's
fun we got 745 people up in here Dam
it's growing people catching
on all
right so I'm trying to get this dirt
node to work properly here I'm actually
going
[Music]
to
my dogs are going crazy you taking off
yeah that's why they're going crazy cool
all right yeah love you see you
later my dogs are running all over the
place right now they having a good time
hey yo Clint dude that that solo node
you got going there yeah done render it
it's
finished yeah I'm trying to get
H yeah I feel like the the spread maybe
needs to go up or
something maybe the
distribution I'm not seeing
enough of this
metal Paul he he wants this to get back
on the Mac PC topic cuz for example uh
programs crashing is much rare on a Mac
as far as my experience goes um I don't
know I've experienced the wheel of death
many
times but the reason I use PC is because
um I love playing video games
so you know I grew up with one too and
my dad built
PCS and yeah you know what I'm used to
David David Turk is like it crashes all
the
time yeah it it your computers are very
complicated things you know they're
going to crash
yeah yeah there's no such thing as a
computer that won't crash you know it's
like that's very
true so I'm just trying to get this
scratch texture up in
here all right radius 05
Maybe H what's the best way to reflect
this maybe to reflect some light I just
want to have some light to reflect
here push this
back because I need to see where these
scratches are taking place I could do
the solo trick you
know and let's definitely turn that
light
down but this will help show me what's
shiny versus what's
matte
I feel
like this dirt node is doing a little
bit of something
here but I want to break this up with
some scratch textures
so this kind of gets Advanced here this
is when I'm going to bust out a noise
node come on what the
heck noise octane noise sweet projection
with noise I always set the projection
to uh XYZ to
uvw that way it perfectly wraps your
noise around any objects
um and then I set my contrast to 100
always because that way I'm actually
able to see what I'm doing and the
transform looks like it needs to come
way
down there you go so I'm using this
noise map to break up
my scratches and
whatnot so from here
basically we want to combine this with
the dirt node
so we want the dirt
node instead of being uniform across the
entire edge of this thing we just want
the scratches to be on certain parts of
it so let's see if we can get our dirt
node back up and that's kind of going
across the edges of this thing our
radius we can go to
one and
then just so we can see clearly I'm
going to boost up the strength which we
will take down in a
minute but then I think I'm going to use
a multiply node I believe it's a
multiply node to combine these two
textures
together okay it's not so we need to do
let's try flipping them
okay that didn't work definitely not a
multiply node let's try an add
node and we'll pipe the dirt in there
there you go you see that you see how
it's
like the noise map is only on the edges
and instead of across the entire Edge
it's just the the noise so what we want
to do now instead of doing it with this
noise I want to do it with a scratch
texture so let me take another one of
these let me actually take this
multiply this mixed material setup we
have I'm going to copy it control drag
and just move
it over here if you hold shift it'll
grab the entire
setup and we'll just bring this on over
so instead of the
noise I want to use this scratch texture
so let's see what this looks
like yeah there you go so now it's only
scratched up on the edges there that
looks super
cool yeah that's
awesome and then if we want to go to the
next level we can actually
use this whole setup with this ad and
everything like this whole
tree I'll delete the node or the noise
let's take this whole setup and apply
this to the bump
channel right up in here on
the Chrome material that way it actually
eats into the board I'm going to try
that I'll throw that into the bump and
you can see it's kind of eating into it
just a little
bit maybe I need to invert
it it's hard to
tell yeah it's nice and chunky and
scratched
that's pretty sweet I'm happy with
this we can get rid of this
light and we want to make sure so you
see all these fireflies all these little
dots here we want to get rid of that so
the best way to do that is to go to your
octane settings we have way too many
samples so set that to a th and it's the
GI clamp you set that to one and it kind
of takes care of
it and also we just need a couple you
know go ahead yeah go ahead I uh I
always set it to one as well but on that
Crystal render I did a week or two ago I
had to I had to up it to 10 oh really
okay cuz uh when I set it down to one
the light from my scene wasn't really
interacting with the crystal the way I
wanted it to and upping the GI clamp
brought back a lot of those highlights
that were just being clamped out I
guess but if I if I said it to his
default way too many
fireflies uh but 100 was too much and
one was not enough okay interesting yeah
or the the other way one was too much
and 100 was not enough so 10 was a
pretty good yeah so now I find myself
just setting it to 10 rather than
one for sure yeah I think it's dependent
on like the scene and the scale of the
scene um at least what I've learned from
David um octane
Jesus
yeah dude everyone's trying to get us on
blender
dude good
luck
hilarious
Rico thank you for the Super Chat that
is very generous of you look at me when
I talk I'm looking at you right now I'm
looking at you right now it's a little
lagged but I'm looking at you
all right this is looking sweet
[Music]
um I'm pretty happy with this Ren I'm
going to you I'm going to let's see what
you got oh boy he said oh
boy what you got going on
Ren I'm just trying to dial in the
animation here getting getting my curves
set for sure it's like I I mess with one
uh setting so I'm basically animating
three attributes here my Z position my y
position and my uh single axis rotation
for P I guess I don't know what axis p
is but anyway uh this one that we're
looking at is the axis that I'm spinning
so got like a little bit of a bump as it
as it comes
down
see
that
nice yeah but now I'm trying to get this
to work so right now it's not doing
anything technically accurate like now
it's up in the air and then accelerates
forward so I actually I have to kind of
keep my Z position constant throughout
all of this so I'm going to take both of
those key frames and delete them
and basically from right here I'll I'll
set my key
frame to right
there this over and I'm going to have to
my have my
rotation be
like this is going to be
rough well what
the why is that happening that key frame
yo shout outs to the mods from
modding Daren and Soto I see you always
doing a good
job yeah y'all y'all me don't be
spamming we got a couple mods up in
here Ren read Motors and
physics wait what oh no I looked at your
screen and and like you your head was
just like looking into the corner I was
like oh you're just reading
chat yeah no I just went over there just
to check up on it real quick
uh someone mentioned I should do this
with motors and
physics uh
Joel Mamer Joel mamir oh maimer dude
that's like the that's like the Chris
Schmid method is to do it with uh
physics actually and I was actually
considering that the problem is I have
no idea how but I was like what would be
ideal is if I can actually rig up some
sort of dynamic system so that it just
automatically doesn't clip through the
ground and all I have to do is animate
like one attribute where basically it's
like all right it approaches here and
then goes up to here and then like the
rest of it just kind of like sticks I
don't know how to do that um so I'm just
kind of manually brute forcing it uh so
my what if I delete that key
frame nope definitely needed that key
frame
maybe my curves are just way too big is
that Tri and air man it takes a long
time to make something nice to make
something look good it takes a lot of
effort a lot of
time ren do you want the screws to be
black matte black with like scratched
Chrome and dirt inside of them or do you
want them to just be straight
Chrome I feel like straight Chrome would
be more eye-catching okay yeah I can do
Chrome with like cuz they they they make
nice little like highlight points you
know like little little points of light
to catch your eye cool yeah yeah um I'll
do that then I'll make a like a chrome
material with some dirt inside of it and
I think that'll actually be really nice
um cuz I got definitely need to add the
dirt certainly need to add the dirt so
I'm I'm going to switch back over to me
here um if you want me to switch back
over just let me know I'll be building
out this like Chrome dirt
texture
sure all right so I'm G start with this
with this guy right here I
guess we'll grow this out uy is the
shortcut to grow your
selection there we go um I'm going to
make a
new Chrome material which is just glossy
and we'll click and drag and put this
guy right on here all right so it's a
white a white
screw um but let's go ahead and change
the index to one and that'll make it
Chrome and we'll give it some roughness
cuz that looks a little weird so 0.1
maybe 02
roughness
um
Graham I think I'm saying that right
maybe not but uh say hey Clint and ren
just wanted to say you're both my
favorite Corridor cast members a that's
awesome um your learning blender these
streams help keep it up yeah thank you
so much that is awesome I'm glad that
you're learning something thanks for the
kind
words okay so we want to put dirt up in
this thing we can't put dirt up in this
thing unless we have a dirt texture so
let's just go ahead and make one real
quick I'll make a diffuse
material and I'll just uh oh Clint what
what I need help I need help come back
to my screen all right I'm on you what's
up I don't know what I did but now I
can't select my key frames anymore and
when I try to do that I end up with this
like time selection how do I whoa how do
I out of this time selection
um I don't know but I'm I'm sure someone
in the chat is about to give you the
answer um hey yes son Let's what if you
close it close your dope sheet and
reopen
it let's see if that
worked nope okay try hitting
r
r that did it okay what was that Eric
Shimmer thank you that's great or Eric
Shimmer that was it that was totally it
what what did that do Eric what did that
do here see if it toggles any lights up
up
above
something's changing yeah you see that
when you hit R
yeah what is that switch in
between I don't
know oh Don yo we got Don all in the
third what's up dude Don yo what up Don
hey man I am currently listening to your
conversation with EJ I'm like two hours
in uh your your YouTube video your
Instagram live stream
uh a lot of lot of great information in
it I've been uh I've been watching it
yeah man same R Ren sent it to me um
last night so I was watching it last
night that's freaking awesome yeah Don
is amazing he's a VR XR um CG artist and
uh yeah he us a cinema educator he's an
educator he he worked at uh DreamWorks
educating for a while um now he's doing
his own thing he's doing crypto art and
he's helped me and ren both a lot um
learning about crypto Arts so we're very
very excited to get into it speaking of
crypto Sherpas Don is another crypto
Sherpa y crypto
Sensei Sensei yeah seriously yeah he's
like um helped me and Ren so much
definitely give Donna a look here he's
got a lot of good stuff on his
Channel all right play okay we're
getting closer we're getting
closer
yeah it's all about just
like it's just way too fast right
[Music]
now but it's it's it's it's kind of it's
getting there yeah your motion is good
it's all
about it's getting it's getting close
closer I wouldn't say it's close but
it's closer yeah
definitely DA's like all the sherpers
yay oh boy he
yeah crypto Sensei I like that yeah
Krypto crypto Sensei sounds
cool but Sherpa I was using Sherpa cuz
he's like guiding the way you know like
helping us down the trail the path yeah
absolutely um cuz it's a very new space
and a lot of people don't know about it
a lot of people don't know how to how to
do it even if you're an artist you know
and Don has been helping with that and
same so uh same for Daffy as
well yo I'm just psyched that on all of
the all the biggest uh crypto uh
platforms I got the username Wen yeah
dude that's sick yeah that's when you
know it's like early super
early um all right so two super chats to
get into nbv says uh more leverage for
Houdini tell Sam about Houdini engine
you can modify procedural assets in real
time through a game engine interesting
that was actually a big reason why I
decided to try to learn Houdini is
because it would complement the skill
sets of both Peter and Sam with uh
unreal so ideally i' would be able to
make something and they can incorporate
it into unreal very smart yeah very
smart but I'm still a ways away from
doing any of that I don't expect Sam to
dive into Houdini at all I mean he might
you know he's already deep and unreal
like there's no reason to like yeah
that's like buying that's like buying
two cars at once it's
like I don't know maybe that's not the
best analogy it's like it's like buying
two cars at once it's like getting
getting two um like jrpgs at once and
you're like which one should I play and
like they're both like 120
hours um 127 hours and then Rico uh he
says what did Nick think about our
R-rated uh Spy Kids
idea and this was actually something
that you guys been talking about they're
like oh doing our rated Spy Kids and me
and Peter were on the couch at the same
time when ni was like what are we going
to do next and both both Peter and I
looked at each other like Spy Kids and
it was like it was perfect I think it's
definitely something that we're thinking
about so we'll see I don't
know all right back to
it yeah they're saying I should look at
the uh curb video that we released last
year as reference but guess what I don't
need no reference I
have come on key frames you can do
it um Zombie Slayer man thank you you
guys are killing with the super chats
today thank you so much um he says Hey
Clinton Ren been binging Corridor videos
for weeks to de-stress after work to
land a job starting on Monday as a cyber
SEC consultant sweet congrats that's
awesome congratulations thanks for
thanks for the Super Chat and thanks for
uh for hanging out with
us we're still going strong we got 678
people up in
here all right I'm switching back to me
let's do this chrome dirt thing so we
got our dirt texture we got our Chrome
texture okay and our Chrome texture is
applied to the to the bolt we want to
mix them together in a special way so
I'm going to make another actually no I
don't even need to use a mix
material I don't think I
do I think I just need to set my Chrome
texture no I'll I'll I'll do it with a
mix material why not so I'll make a new
mix material I'll apply the dirt and the
Chrome to it right and I probably should
be naming all my stuff
but you know we're moving quick here
I'll apply it and make sure that my tag
is my selection tag is applied
sweet so now what I need to do is
basically make sense of this node view
I'm start moving stuff around okay okay
I don't know why it's set up like
this
what
what oh that's a bug yeah I love that
our friends are jumping in the Stream
here that's so cool it is man yeah it's
freaking sick thanks for showing up
everyone dude we got Christian wait
really Christian fishr yeah he said sup
boy Christi in the house dude freaking
Christian man Christian is the best
freaking love
Christian I got everybody in here it is
popping
off we just need Dean and then we can
play Smash Bros and we can three stock
him yeah Dean sucks to smash I mean if
we're being honest about it yeah I me if
we're being completely honest he's like
trash yeah straight up straight up like
when I think when I when you know
Tuesday is trash day for me so every
time I wake up on Tuesday I just think
of Dean
[Laughter]
immediately
it's like oh it's Dean
day Dean
day so we didn't have enough time to set
up the smash break like stream setup but
I definitely want to do that for next
time I want to have a smash break set up
so we can just take some smash braks
together um not this time it'll have to
be next time it was a really good
idea
but you know that idea panned out just
about as well as Dean playing smash it's
true might as well not even TR actually
no no that's that that's an insult to
how well this uh stream is
going I love it I love
it and Dean's not here to defend
himself getting that trash
talk all right so I'm just trying to
adjust my dirt
node so this thing
works oh there we go starting to get a
little
something um Christian Christian's
trying to jump in with some trash talk
but it like Auto hit it it like Auto
moderated like I had to physically Go
and show his
comment that's hilarious that's weird I
don't see Christian in the
chat
he said smash break is going to be
stressful for you when I'm whooping your
ass oh I see there
yeah dude it'd be fun to just do smash
streams
like like some week nights or yeah dude
I mean I'm I'm super down I think the
plan is we're going to try to get that
working on the website oh heck
yeah but I mean honestly like I mean
what's to stop us from just you know
doing a smash stream on on your YouTube
channel like on Sunday or something you
know like yeah absolutely I mean it's
not exactly effect focused at all but
whatever I mean
whatever all right I think God dang it
this freaking dirt node
dude so I don't want it on the edges I
just want it in the crevices and it's
hard to tell the difference because this
thing is so
small maybe I crank the tolerance then
move the radius back down dude uh TJ TJ
weel whitel yeah TJ
whitel uh I think that's a German anyway
he's saying check out Shapiro 500 Loop
tutorials for a sick way to Loop this um
dude that guy's amazing yeah he is very
talented I'm already aware of Shapiro uh
I not Ben Shapiro um I think his name is
Gavin yeah Gavin Shapiro gav Shapiro I
learned how to Loop animations from him
watching those um so basically when I
did my uh Maxon like motion
designer class whatever thing um the
motion show last year it was the one on
like the full workflow on on my channel
um he did his on looping animations and
it blew me away and that's the only
reason I was able to do that like zen
garden looping animation at Corridor and
then oh really the same one for the
singing bowls like it's because I watch
watched um Gavin's
videos boy dude my
animation oh oh my God it's getting
close getting this rotation curve down
is
challenging dang I'm like running into
dumb issues with my dirt node here I
feel like it should be
uh working better but I think it's on
such a small
scale so then you can use render region
here to just like only render the part
that you're trying to get
to but I think at the end of the day too
it's like we're going to be viewing this
from way out
here and that is totally fine I'm more
concerned with the dirt like in the
corner of the tire like this wheel weld
thing um Roy it's live dude it's live
believe it or
not yo what up Roy D Roy's like shout
out to Roy Roy's like what what's going
on this is this is this is live like in
real time what you can barely hang
on it's it's hard I I I keep getting
distracted by going back to this uh this
chat this chat here I know um but that's
good it's good yeah the chat you see
Gavin just sold uh that freaking looping
triangle thing on I forget which
platform I think maybe super rare uh he
did a drop of of that thing and it
included the project files oh that's
very smart so that other people can like
use use that project file to attach
stuff to like his little triangles that
spinning I know Arc did do you know Arc
you know Arc I forget his I don't know
his name I don't know I don't know Arc
but I'm I'm maybe I know Arc I don't
know I mean I've shown you his videos
before uh but maybe they're just
disconnecting who it is for you
um is he is I think he got a hold of one
the spaceman
guy
no all right yeah oh dude Cornelius sold
his um I don't know if it's still up or
not but it's the octane not the octane
splash screen it's it's the like the
2069 ad one you know the one I'm talking
about where he's like looking up at this
sci-fi graffiti
wall maybe I know you've seen it dude
like probably it's some of the craziest
CG work it's um Cinema 40 in O didn't he
do he did the the whole like he started
the whole like astronaut Trend didn't he
cuz he had that astronaut hovering
outside the phone booth on the wet
pavement yeah oh according to B he
didn't start the astronaut Trend but he
was one of the early early early guys to
start doing that yeah fair enough yeah
he's the guy his art is on the octane
splash screen um of the astronaut in the
foone booth that's Cornelius um he had a
piece or was I don't know what the
splash screen is now yeah I don't know
it might be the same thing I'm not sure
but his piece was up on super
last night I checked it and it was at
ethereum last night really
yeah I hope I hope it's more um at this
point which is about
$20,000 for that piece yeah that's crazy
yeah it's insane uh cuz I was marveling
at his freaking syringes that he put up
recently yeah he made these like super
high reses syringes and he did something
that I found very interesting cuz he
added dust to all the syring by
basically uh voxal the model like using
the volume measure you know and so that
that way he's able to retopologize it to
be really really low poly and he then
then used octane scatter on a couple
little tiny pieces of Geo to scattered
across the the syringes and those little
tiny pieces of Geo are dust yeah and
using octane scatter he's able to get a
whole bunch of it but so that's a way to
like kind of get that extra little
detail on top of the syringes without
using texture Maps you know know and
it's like it's so smart it catches the
eye differently yeah it and and it
catches the light yeah it definitely
catches the light um and you if you
backlight it it looks like hair I mean
it's basically hair standing up on the
end of your model but it's just
scattered little pieces of geometry
scattered around it's
perfect all right I'm feeling pretty
good about these bolts as well as
the side of this thing I might do a
version
where ah no I got to keep moving I think
it's time to do the wheel well now and
actually have some dust collecting on
the inside of this thing I think that's
the way to
go Ren you got anything to show or
should I stay uh stay on my screen I
mean I'm I'm I'm still kind of in the
same same spot here I mean feel free to
send it over for a quick update yeah
here you go boom it's on
you I'm going to actually grab some
water while you um give everyone an
update okay so I will be
RB so basically everyone I'm trying to
animate a curb
nudge the one wheel climbing a
curb and if you want some real footage
of of that we actually released a video
on the corridor crew Channel last year
where I tried to teach my friends how to
do it and in that video I showed many
examples of myself doing it especially
at the end towards the uh through the
patreon shout outs
and there's lots of great reference
there this actually happening this is
honestly like probably the most useful
like Advanced skill you can get on a one
wheeel because it's like incredibly
useful for getting around town sometimes
there aren't little you know anytime you
got to get off your board Bo to go up a
sidewalk you don't have to get off your
board anymore you can just climb the
sidewalk anyway I
uh I had this idea last night or no two
nights ago I had this idea what if I
animated this excellent one whee pint
model from Reed who is late night
renders on Instagram very talented uh CG
artist and
he sent me this one whe pint model last
year like months ago at this point
you're like hey use this however you
want hope to see something cool and I
was like sweet I hope to make something
cool someday uh and that that day is
today so it's all about just trying to
get
the position right this is close this is
close
but not quite there yet oh wow actually
this is getting really
close looks great okay I'm going I'm
going to play I'm going to play
it okay so actually I think this is way
too slow of a
leadup uh so I'm going to take this Z
key frame and move it way
over so it's
faster actually that's getting close
that's getting close that's really
good it's about that
fast are you g to have it continue to
drive drive
off yeah yeah that's that's the hope and
goal here so that I can actually have it
Loop so that like it goes from one
curb to the next curb but I'm going to
tackle that after I I kind of nail down
this this one curb animation here yeah
so you like get the little piece and
then you'll duplicate it across
everything to make it look way more
complicated yeah
exactly I'm just enjoying a little
cookie little cookie snack and then I'm
back to
Texan oh yeah MC dafy that's the that's
the piece 688 a d 6088 a
a
Ean Ewan
Ean I think one of those was
correct I'm glad man thank you I've been
enjoying doing this it's it's hard work
but it's very enjoyable and it's cool
that I get to do it with Ren here today
so I'm excited I'm excited for this
piece too man like this going to be cool
nice little
collab
sweetest gravy
nine that's it s tweet no uh he said to
animate the one wheel you should make
the tire a separate object parent to the
body and rotate it independently from
the body that is actually my plan that
is exactly what I intend to do it is
already a separate piece from the body
it is parented correctly and once I get
the the sort of animation for the whole
one wheel climbing this curb here then
I'll go through and actually do the
animation for the tire so that as it's
rolling along we get the correct
rotation for the tire sweet and the
motor and and yeah the motor will rotate
as well
sweet B that looks great man that looks
really good I'll play
it I think I think the the snap is a
little on the quick side and it's still
technically clipping so I wonder if I
can delay this a little
bit o okay but if I that maybe
that'll yeah cuz the whole thing about
curb nudging is that if the tire hits
the curb first before before you start
doing the pop you're not going to climb
that curb you're just going to bounce
off of it makes sense
so I have to start having this rotate
much
sooner that's getting close that's
getting
close oh dude oh yeah we're getting
there we're getting there
sweet okay so now
my man I guess if if the tires clipping
through the curb a little bit it won't
be that big of a deal right no because
it depends on your angle like you're
probably not going to be looking at it
from that angle
right yeah probably
not I was just kind of hoping to avoid
using a curve here on the Z
axis all right I'm going switch back
over and uh yeah sounds good talk about
I want to yeah I'm I'm going to take a
moment
to yeah take a break watch what what you
got sweet um I I want to see these
textes Carnitas uh thank you for the
Super Chat and I got you man yeah we'll
get we'll get some more live streams
like this um it's fun doing it with
Partners man it's a little easier on on
just me doing it and I think it's it's
more fun for everybody so it's a good
time all right so I want to get um some
dirt collected up in this one wheel let
me give you an example real
quick so I don't know if you can see it
but inside of the wheel there's actually
like dirt and like fingerprints in the
wheel well it's might be a little hard
to see but it's definitely there you can
oh dude you got to get that Rim
scratched up too the outer rim next to
the tire that always gets scratched up
yeah
absolutely but yeah there's um you see
like little dirt prints there's like
fingerprints in here and yeah I want to
get
that so I got my dirt texture it's just
a you know diffuse solid it's just one
color and um I also have the engine
itself that came with the
model I'll be right back I got to go
Wrangle my dogs who are outside
apparently yeah yeah go for
it so I'm going to use again what we did
for the screws I'm going use a dirt node
so that's the mount right it will be
with a dirt node and you can see it's
already kind of
working um but let's tweak it a little
bit here let's set the let's set it to
10 all
right and we want this dirt node to
be yeah we want it like that it's on the
edges so then we can scale it back a
little bit we'll set it to one and we'll
set the radius to
two so there's like a bunch of dirt kind
of in this
area in all the grooves and whatnot so
maybe
let's see if we can't keep working this
so that it kind of meets towards the
center so maybe the radius
is 10 like that and the strength is
.5 maybe we can pull back the spread
[Music]
um whoa Alex
funky and then I'll render the region so
we can get a quicker preview of what
we're
doing so this is a this is a dirt layer
across everything but we also we want to
throw it down with a or rather break it
up with a surface imperfection so let's
get rid of that or not get rid of it
we'll unlink it we know that this is
where we want it to be so let's bring
out our next thing it's an image
texture and I'll load one of
my Surface
imperfections um if you guys want to get
some of these there's a link to them in
the description
below um service imperfection 4K and
dust yeah like
maybe what would be the best one or
maybe like water or we could do
both this is like wiped
dust and I'll need to just adjust the
projection which I'll always set to box
and the
transform and I think I need to scale
this
down and maybe take the gamma let's see
invert
it oo there we go I'll be right back
again yeah sounds
good so that's getting a nice like dirt
kind of smear look across
everything I'll scale it up a little bit
and I want to combine this with another
dirt texture so let's just control drag
all this stuff up so we'll save that and
let's change out this one let's do it
for like
a streaks or something you know
something grungy and nasty like that
could be kind of cool you know uh cold
film thanks for joining man I'll see you
next time glad you're able to make
it so cold film
peace so yeah um ren do you think this
is too much this like grungy wheel
texture like I'm going to combine them
and scale it back a little bit but do
you think having this like one drippy
streak will be too much for the like
rotation of the
wheel yeah maybe maybe it's a little
much
uh let's see maybe we could just do like
another dust one but it's more subtle oh
wait hold up my thing went is no long
okay now it's back something like that
maybe just general dust and then we can
break this
up we'll use a mix texture on this so I
will yeah cuz the the wheel well is
typically not
scratched the uh but it gets dirt it
doesn't get scratched though you know
like inside yeah the outside of the rim
definitely does get all scratched yeah
this is all dirt right
now and I'm just breaking this up so I'm
going to break up this mix texture here
cuz I'm using both of those
nodes um or both of those image textures
to basically be combined together but
I'm going to break them up with like a
uh a smear fingerprint texture like you
went to go grab your wheel you know and
it kind of just like uh you smeared some
of the Dirt away so maybe we can try and
replicate that I'll pipe in the same
projection and
transform and I'll see if I can't crank
this
up to like eight and then we'll solo it
so we can see
it okay I'm not seeing
it I got a
snack Slinky linky HD thanks for the
Super
Chat apprciate
it
um oh here's another way like if you're
having trouble seeing your
stuff you always want to put it into
like the most obvious spot so I'll just
pipe it into the amount as opposed to
the amount for the mix texture and we'll
just make sure that this looks good so I
think I actually need to invert it and I
think that's what it is so that's
actually some really nice fingerprint
texture there that feels really good and
I actually want to use this to get rid
of what is down in here
so let's see if I can't undo that pipe
that in believer designs thank you again
for the Super Chat man um always been
waiting for live stream with Ren yeah
will there also be one with Ian Hubert
in the
future um maybe I think he might be down
we'll see that'd be
sweet um and yeah you enjoy the the
surface imperfection Maps you use them
all the time now that's awesome dude
thank you
very sick all right um into the scene
and see what we can
see okay I've seen this a lot now
everyone keeps commenting that I should
make the the tire squishy and deform
when it hits the the the curb the
problem is that like it doesn't actually
deform that much in real
life and that's what I'm going for here
I'm going for like as realistic as
possible and the truth of the matter is
that like it kind of doesn't really
deform it deforms when you're standing
on it so it's slightly flatter down on
the
bottom um for sure but it doesn't yeah
it doesn't really def because when the
tire hits the curb see that's the thing
doing a curb nudge you're not really
hitting the curb with the tire at all
the idea is that you're you're you're
kind of like trying to climb up it
before the tire has a chance to really
bounce off of it and you're utilizing
ing the spinning of it to to actually
climb up so if if the tire is actually
hitting the curb hard enough to
deform it's you're not going to make it
up the curb you're just going to bounce
off of it in fact you can see it in in
our curb nudge video uh last year
everyone's trying to climb that curb but
all their boards keep bouncing off is
because they're not trying to climb soon
[Music]
enough dang I'm trying to find the right
node
to make this
work I think that's
it no
um dang this is tough it's weird it's
like basically I have
this this material here and I want to
use this to
erase this stuff here it's like a second
mixed material almost but I know I can
do this with the nodes I'm just
like
H it's tough I'm getting confused
there's a lot of different little like
little maps and
stuff multip yeah multiply should work
but all the stuff is already white
anyway technically what it needs is
like uh multiply and then I'll throw
this in there but then I need to invert
this or
something or May maybe I throw like a
gradient map on
this and invert
these no but that's going to do the same
thing
H difficult difficult subtract yeah I
think
subtract
could work that was my first inclination
was to do
subtract maybe I need to switch them
around dang it what the
heck
man it's not
working divide by zero do I even have
divide in
here maybe I should just simplify this
and it's just the
one guy going into here
and then this guy let's see what this
one looks
like we'll invert
this
and then maybe we'll give this a octane
gradient and crunch its
values and we'll solo it so we can see
what's going
on something like
that
and I want to use this to punch through
this guy
so let's
see
multiply this one and this
one and then invert this oh this is so
like
convoluted ah and
it's h it's okay it's kind of doing it
you see how it's like punching out this
look I keep thinking you're talking to
me and I should be
looking okay but then that's getting
everything on this one
let's throw a gradient on this
guy
h
oh because it's in the
multiply that's
why maybe we add it let's try adding
it oh is that it I think that's it
there it is yep all right so it just
needed to be put into the
ad there it is all right so the
fingerprints are being taken away from
the inside of that now we need to
combine
this with the dirt node as
well
Andy Boy you've made time for one of the
streams dude thank you awesome
awesome sweet okay so now all of
this is working working together to get
us this look so all of this stuff
here and then let's get this grading up
here and we can probably get rid of this
one make sure you guys save your work
save it save
it cool all right now what we want to do
is we want to take all of this and only
see this
dirt where this dirt node allows us to
see the dirt all right so we want to
multiply these together I believe
hopefully that is the
answer the dirt node boom and it might
be an ad I don't know
yet all right so that's combining both
we don't want that we don't want to
combine
them let's real quick just try switching
these around it might be just the order
of how we got it in the scene nope so
let's try and
add that seems a little too subtle but
maybe
interesting
[Music]
um ranked on the dirt map let's try 10
yeah that's I mean that's basically
it that's basically it and then we can
take let's see let's take this
dirt texture and drop it down so we're
getting as much of it as possible and
then I think I'll bring the power down
to like5
five oh wait weird does the power need
to come
up so it's too much right now I think
there's too much dirt
so I think we just need to scale this
back um we can add a a gradient right
the tail end of
things and we can say whatever um
whatever's white turn to black so if you
turn white to
black it'll go away or no it's the
opposite so if you turn black to white
it'll go away you see that so let's just
make instead of it being completely
white let's just turn it gray or maybe a
little brighter so you're able to
control how much of that dirt actually
is in that wheel Weld and we just want a
little
bit
very very subtle and another thing we
want to do too is scratch up the edges
of this thing so you're going to see
this Edge right here is going to be
completely scratched up so let's see if
we can't get that look let's go to our
polygon mode and see where this would
be all right so I'm going to do UL for
Loop selection and then u y a few times
to grow that
selection and we have
a nice little selection there that's
where we want the scratched pieces so
I'm going to hit this button the set
selection button you can also go up to
select and hit uh where is
it where are you set selection right
there yeah and that's going to make this
little selection node or selection icon
for us that will pipe into our uh our
material but let's make a new one let's
make a new mix material and this mix
material is going to include this big
one that we just worked on as well as
has this chrome
texture and we'll go ahead and apply
that to the engine and apply the
selection
tag to the material all right so now we
just need
to break this up in a specific way so
again instead of let's see
here
where is everything all
right this is it right over here
everything is kind of
crazy we just got to organize things a
little
[Music]
bit I think I got to update my octane
doing some like buggy weird stuff on me
what the
heck going try this one more
time
so let's go into the octane node editor
and select this material let's go ahead
and drag in a mix
material we'll also drag in our Chrome
material and we'll just pipe these in
this way I'm trying to just work around
some bugs
here and this now is working properly so
I'll pipe this up into our engine and
applyer selection
tag make sure you guys save and this
should work yes looks
good hanbon 23 do I plan on having more
guests on the stream absolutely yeah
it's a good time it's really
fun Ren are you alive what's going on on
your
end I'm
good I'm meeting my PB and J uncrushable
oh heck yeah dude you got an uncrustable
right
now heck yeah
dang dude that sounds really good
actually all right so we got a dirt node
up on here I'll set the strength to 10
so I can see what's going on and I'll
take the radius down to like2 I want to
just get this on the
[Music]
edges I have a dilemma here you want to
switch back to my screen yeah yeah yeah
all right I'm on you
so I'm getting pretty close to final
animation here
um we just if we just look at this side
view here it's
like whoa okay hold up so okay my my
problem is over here on the dope sheet
yeah you know I got this i got this uh
this graph
here but my key frame is below where I
can reach it here but if I try to like
I I I'm only stretching it I can't like
scroll within this graph yeah I've had
that issue before and I don't can only
go left and right when I try to like
yeah so I can't even access this key
frame um that's an issue I've run into
as well does anyone in the chat have an
answer for
that it's great man because I learn so
much from the chat honestly like I'll
run into stuff I know this is cool and
like they'll help out um it says can you
alt click the axis on the
left what axis axis try holding control
like this thing try holding
control oh
on increase the time line with r try try
shift yeah tried shift Control Alt all
different permutations of that on the
line with the numbers on the line with
the
numbers on the line with the
numbers uh yeah which numbers up here I
don't not y all got to be
specific try holding Mouse
scroll middle Mouse button scroll I
don't know yeah this this curls the
entire dope sheet and I just need this
area specifically
inside yeah the Z it's like if I hold
down control I can like zoom in and out
but only in the left and right Direction
and if I grab this thing here I can
scale it up and down but I can't like
scroll within this sort
of Base
here so y'all
um try try and if you guys are't trying
to help try and describe the whole thing
in one comment cuz I don't know what
you're talking about before or where he
was like I don't know where he
was um you can try closing and reopening
the dope sheet
I did that I did that last time and it
didn't work see um try hitting f f will
focus your
selection
uh
no no f is just going backwards in time
f and g I have set to uh scrolling the
timeline um try snapping the window to
the top or the
right yeah didn't fix it either it's
like it it doesn't have anything to do
with the window it's it's everything
within this one little parameter here
like if I maximize this it's still not
visible it's this key frame that's down
at the end of this line right here yeah
it's
like I don't know how to expand this
number group here yeah I I've run into
the same thing I don't know um one guy's
just saying delete and Rey it it'll
probably pop in that's not an option I
can't even select it oh you can I mean I
guess I could select the key frame in
over here sure but I mean like I I don't
want that to be the solution see the see
the far right key
frame like the the far right key
frame yeah one
moment it be I think this key
frame no it's on your du sheet no yeah
that yeah it's that
one like cuz you can see it up in there
yeah that guy yeah like I can I can move
it I just okay now if I have it selected
no F won't do it
um alt right
click no that's not doing
it h
weird yeah that's
weird I mean I guess I can go to
view
um
so it says select that key frame and
change the value on the
right again that doesn't solve that's a
way to get around this so I want to
actually figure out how to solve this
problem of like changing the scaling of
the vertical scaling of my dope sheet
see I can do it left and right I can
change the scaling left and right I also
want to change it up and down and more
than just doing this this is just like
changing the scale of that but I want
the the actual input numbers to change
totally yeah um he says s will frame The
View okay let's try
s what just happened I think you zoomed
in like
crazy okay yeah try try
H
yeah
that that didn't do it dang
um brutal I don't want to change the
value of this key frame what if what if
this is the key frame I want it to be on
what if this is the exact value and time
I want it to be yeah
totally top three icons SEL the second
the third put the second one see that is
f curve switch to F curve mode oh boy
I F curve okay okay that may have that
may have oh oh how' you do
it so it's this icon up here but this is
also still not exactly what I want but
kind
of I lost all the others uh this is
interesting okay so if I was in the dope
sheet view okay but if I go to the F
view I can now at least select this key
frame that's okay that's close to what I
want so what is this third view oh
that's not what I want um how can I get
a f curve mode inside the dope
sheet F curve mode okay I didn't even
know about that
yeah me
neither I select that key F curve show
velocity um a velocity is just a speed
with a direction H I don't know who I'm
telling that to okay just random science
facts to no one
like you went into like this
mode dude that's hilarious for no reason
well like speed and velocity like I've
gotten that question like what's the
difference between speed and velocity
and it's like they're the same except
velocity has the implication of a
direction ah interesting because speed
is just speed it's going anywhere but
velocity implies that it's a speed but
going a certain way for
sure I don't know why I brought that up
no one asked that question dude cuz
you're always in science mode you're
like describing random scientific facts
it's
great yo by show of hands dude what if I
took this person's advice and actually
hit alt f4 dude the stream would
probably
break it'd be
over um but I want to I want to say by a
show of hands who has seen Ren's up
video
nobody
no one oh here it comes yeah a lot of
people yeah oh boy yeah there it is oh
my
God sweet nothing like asking a question
and then just like radio silence for 10
seconds and all of a sudden a flood of
people oh my God it's another flood
Jesus Christ yeah that's sick that's
awesome that's cool thanks everyone yeah
that's just like that's Ren's latest
science video he's got like six more
seven more maybe more I don't
know oh I've only got like another three
that I actually have like an idea for
what's one is I want to definitely do
the solar panel one how many solar
panels would power the world yeah that'd
be sick that's one that I've tried doing
twice before now though third times a
charm you tried you tried writing it
twice before yeah it was hard dude it
was so hard it was probably the hardest
one to try yet just cuz it's like
there's so many different things to
consider and how do I boil that down to
like a simple little thing it's
like energy is complex um I want to do
one where we talk about how much data
has been consumed how how much data you
can store on a device like show like a
floppy disc versus like a one terabyte
micro SD card I like that one I like
that one a
lot yeah and hopefully one day I'll be
able to do the Moon video the Moon video
would be sick too man yeah
lots of sick stuff here's a here's a
hint on what that idea is basically NASA
has this uh Mission planned or or
proposed they have a proposed mission on
the moon that will basically turn an
entire
crater into a giant satellite dish like
a Four Mile wide satellite dish and all
they have to do is like lay this tiny
mesh of wires across the whole crater
and it'll act like a satellite dish and
they'll use it to actually look into
deep space cuz it's on the dark side of
the moon so you won't get any
interference from all the radio waves
from Earth so you'll get like a nice
clean signal with a giant satellite dish
looking straight into the deep space
that's really sick um is that is there
like a date on that plan or is it just
something that they've been wanting to
do for a while honestly I don't know um
they have a lot of missions that are
proposed that never actually go anywhere
um so we'll see
when are you going to eat a
terabyte so that was one of the ideas we
had is that like what if I spent $200
and bought this micro SD card just so
that I could eat it dude that uh that
article that you sent me about that
guy who actually ate it you should
accidentally you should you should tell
tell him a little bit about that that's
hilarious okay so like we talked about
this on the podcast and then so people
started sending me like stories of
people actually eating micro SD cards
and this one guy actually did it by
accident he had Tak the micro SD card
out of a drone and he was like juggling
a few different cameras so he just put
the SD card like you know you grab it in
your lips like so here I'll do it right
now like micro SD card and
like and then he like
tripped and accidentally like like
caused it to go into his mouth as he was
inhaling and next thing he knew he
swallowed the SD card dude so but the
problem is that that SD card had all of
the footage that he shot on that drone
for that shoot
day so he had to go to the director and
be like hey I just ate your footage like
literally he was like worried about
being fired he was like going to be
fired and they were like they were livid
they were like dude what
why that's so
funny yeah and and so he had to actually
wait until he uh you know passed it and
had to fish it out of whatever it was
that was passed oh my God all of the all
of the gunk clean it off oh and another
dude sent me a video his baby
accidentally ate a Micro SD card really
and he had to fish it out of his baby's
diaper oh dude he sent me like a poopy
micro SD card picture and apparently
that one worked just fine but the other
dude who lost the Drone footage had to
like do all this special recovery stuff
cuz like the card had gotten corrupted
that's so that's so disgusting
that's freaking hilarious dude oh my god
did you
[Music]
imagine n man it'd be
rough okay I'm I'm
uh I'm getting close like I think I have
like two more textures to do um
basically I'm doing like the hard
plastic bumper oh
really what the hell what the heck oh
There He Go okay now it's back D I'm
still pulling freaking scabs off my
arm all from a washing machine exploding
wait
what
yeah flooded my kitchen so we're like J
and I had like our pots and pans out
trying to catch all the water spewing
out of the wall and then like throw it
over our fence outside at your new place
yeah dude that sounds
horrible it was awful dude it was yeah
had to Jerry rig this whole thing it
wasn't the washing machine's fault it
was the drain going into the wall was
clogged so after a giant wash where like
a whole tub was filled with water it was
trying to drain it and instead drained
it onto my kitchen oh jeez
dude that's so
rough someone was commenting about how I
moved my
arm yo stepen Parker with the gorillas
definitely shout outs to my boy um you
guys GSG he might know I mean well I'm
just I'm just saying like I'm a Donkey
Kong main right now
so dude it's the funniest when you start
making freaking monkey noises while
playing smash you got to Monkey out dude
when you're playing Smash Bros and
you're playing as Donkey Kong and you
just clap someone into the stratosphere
like you got to start screaming
dude all right Ren I'm feeling pretty
good about this um I need to get the
like front bumper plastic chewed up and
stuff and then I think I need to do a
pass on the wheel and maybe the grip
tape I think dude the foot pads yeah the
grip tape the foot pads get some dirt on
on them foot pads maybe I'll do the foot
pads first cuz you're going to see those
oh are you going to put any uh scratches
and stuff on the tire or is the tire
going to be clean no I'm going to dirty
up the tire I think right now I'm going
to do the foot pads and the grip tape to
be all dirty and then I'll do any stuff
underneath the board you probably won't
see
um but I'll probably be done here in the
next 30 to 45
um how do you think you're looking on
your scene when will you be ready to
drop in a
wheel oh God dud I don't
know we we'll keep it up we'll keep
we'll keep doing it if even if we don't
finish it that's okay um we'll get as
close as we
can all right so yeah let's do the grip
tape then
um maybe I'll do these
screws yeah let's do these screws so
basically I'm just going to select the
center point of these
guys holding down shift to select
multiple
polygons and then I'm going to hit
uy on the keyboard to grow my
selection and then I'll drag my uh like
Chrome dirty mix material onto those
guys
let's get our dirt node
up we just have like some shiny points
there it looks pretty sweet yeah right
now what I want to
do I'll go into full view
here I just want to dirty up these foot
pads you know again I know I'm out of
sink I understand we got the technical
difficulties trying to get everything
working here but the foot pads they're a
little dirty I'm going to get some dirt
maybe some scratches on them you
know so that's
next people try still trying to help me
on the
freaking I uh key frame selection
really all right let's see here
grip
tape the grip tape just looks like the
plastic I want to make this
probably I think the grip tape is
actually at a
good a good color I think I just need to
dirty it up
so it's like all of this stuff if I hit
uy here's another tip if you download a
model ever and it's all one piece
chances are it's a combination of like a
number of pieces that they bake down
into one piece so what you can do is
actually select you see how I'm
selecting the foot pad and then if I hit
uy it's going to grow my selection but
it won't go beyond that one piece so I
can like pop the foot pad off and that's
a really easy way to select it
so I know that that little piece there
is my foot pad I also know that this
piece back here is the foot pad so I'm
going to select that grow that selection
and now I have both foot pads the
shortcut is uy for grow selection all
right
so let's see I think I need to apply
this material to the board that way
we're we're able to just manipulate the
single
material
so let's make a new mix material let's
go into the octane node editor I'll
select this this material here which is
just our our board
basically and I'll just kind of organize
this a little bit and it looks like we
have uh maybe I'll duplicate it because
it has a bump pass on it that we don't
want and I'll just update this guy
here bam now we'll go into this one and
we can delete this bump Channel that we
had set up
previously and we want to make a mix
material cuz we want to dirt dirty it up
and we will throw in this dirt
material where are
you getting in the
scene there we go I'm we'll pipe these
guys in material one material to and
then we'll apply this mixed material to
our
Model come
on no I don't want to I don't want to do
that oh
No Object
View
bam
sweet try that one more time bam drag
and drop cool all right so now it's
splitting between the dirt and this uh
this bump here so let's uh let's go
in and let's break this up with just you
know some general
uh dirt here so I'm going use
my Surface imperfection pack once again
the texture projection will be set to
box that way it uniformly distributes
the texture across the objects we have
selected and we're I know that it's
going to have to be scaled way down and
then I'll search
for any one of these like we could do
a a mixture
of I don't know maybe these dust wipes
something like that and go
0.0025 and we can set the gamma to one
to get a little bit more out of it and
maybe that's a little bit too uniform
maybe we need something like this guy
here and it's got to be subtle it's got
to be a subtle
effect
so we take the power
down to two perhaps and we can scale it
up sweet yeah that's not
bad um and then it'd be nice to get
let's see I'm looking at the reference
some scratches in here I think would be
would be nice
so let me take look at the back of this
board sweet nice and dirty I like
it and I'll make a new mix
material let's actually go into this mix
material that we were just working
in and let's go ahead and uh let's drag
in a new mix
material and I'm going to make a
new
yeah I'll make a new octane material
dude I got ghosts in my house wait
what my door just opened on its own are
you for
real
yeah that's super
sketch is it windy where you
are
uh no yeah it is
sorry I'm like it's it's hard to like
talk and also do effects at the same
time I don't know how you do it man no
understood understood all right well
hopefully you don't get snatched up by
some
ghosts all right so I'm going to try and
get some scratches over top of this
thing um so let's pipe in this
material and the amount we'll use an
image texture once again
projection this is this is what we're
doing all the time projection is set the
Box we bust out the transform node and
we set it to like
0.0025 or something and we'll load in a
scratch
texture something
subtle and we need to apply
it to our model so we're going to just
update it
by dragging and
dropping and we could switch these
around bam there we go oo that's looking
cool and then we'll take this uh diffuse
down to like a dark gray or
something so it get some nice little
scratches on it very
subtle and let's take the the scratch
texture we'll take the gamma down to
one and we'll just transform it around
until we get some scratches and shapes
that we like maybe we can scale it down
a little bit
more
0035 that's pretty sweet actually it's
very subtle but it's
cool
um and then to make it easier to see I'm
going to make a new octane hdri um
octane sky here and I'll set it to just
the color we'll set this to
zero and I want to set this to our
visible environment not primary that way
we're able to it's easier to see when
it's against the black
background um another thing we can do
is change out the image texture the the
surface imperfection uh for maybe
something a bit more
scratched you know something like that
or maybe another one of these
guys really scratched yeah that might be
a little too much I think what we had
before was really good um I really like
this subtle scratch scratch number
one and we can even take the gamma down
to like 75 so it shows a bit more of the
image and we can also let's see let's
try grabbing an octane
gradient and just punch it
up and we can render
region maybe we'll do uh
2.2
oh yeah so this one's very subtle but I
like it
cool yeah that's very
nice and I think um as a final little
touch you know we can we can probably
keep going on this it just
depends oh what happened to the Pint
logo
kind of gray
[Music]
out oh is that what we just did
interesting I wonder if it just updated
that onto this
piece
and this looks to
be huh okay so something happened here
and I don't know
what basically our pint logo is been
covered up
completely
and we had scratches on this and I don't
know what happened to our scratches
that's why you save iterations I'm I'mma
save one
now how you doing Ren Control Alt s what
is
that it's a save version ooh save uh
let's see save incremental incremental
yeah yeah so that way it automatically
saves it as a new project file with a
number on it that's very handy yeah
that's right here I'm so used to doing
it the Chrisi method and doing it
manually but I got to do it this way um
also we got win bush in the house what
up Winbush what's going on dude we got
Winbush what up um Winbush got accepted
in a super rare guys and he's gonna be
posting oh dude congrats man yeah yeah
he's um he's going to be posting some
art soonish there's no announcement yet
at least I don't think on wi but um yeah
dude I got to I got to I got to get my
submission in this weekend yeah dude
yeah you do got to make it happen
absolutely yeah figure I'll focus on
super rare first and then get to the
others afterwards but once I can get
super
rare yeah yeah super rare is super rare
is super sick I love it I'm excited
excited to get get going on
it all right so God dang I got to I got
to solve this issue here something
happened
with this mix
material I don't know wait what happened
like basically basically it's all gray
out here the Pint logo is all gray out I
used to have scratches on here but
there's not any scratches
anymore I don't know why that's the
case you're excited for Harry Potter
rated R well that's coming out tomorrow
it's it's kind of
ridiculous uh yeah it's kind kind of
kind of strange it's not exactly rated R
some of it's very rated R others is just
kind of fun yeah yo wait we got Leo in
the Stream Andre Leo oh for
real wait
where where is he where where's my
boy he's cool I like his yeah dude he's
super
sick I don't see Andre
lebrov who said Andre Le
brav uh oh bring Andre leov in the
Stream I misread that I'm
sorry who who said that wow wizard you
got me so excited for a moment dude that
guy's awesome man
um that dude is freaking sweet he's so
nice I actually interviewed him for uh
remember that video I was telling you
about Rand about like organization and
folder structure and
stuff uhuh yeah I interviewed him for
that so I still need to edit all that
stuff together I interviewed like beeple
and uh Andre lav and uh Ian Hubert
blender Guru and a bunch of other people
about their like what are your secrets
for folder organization asset
organization um and like how do you work
efficiently and not just be clicking
around looking for your files all day so
I need to I need to finish that
video D you're doing a live stream I
know what am I
doing n this is
great okay I fixed my issue there we
go this is looking good pretty happy
with
this yeah that's
awesome dude yeah this is looking really
nice um I'm going to dirty up the the
tire next but oh I still want to do one
last thing for
the for the foot pad here I want to give
it some like some really nice
bump and I'll change out my hdri
too
oh J Chen as well what's up hey guys
what's going on J Chen's from uh
PNY and he yeah he helped me do the uh
the render Montage it was it was a
contest and they oh yeah totally that's
right yeah shout outs to Jay and his
kids yeah yo shout out to cavan 3D FM
what's going on over there
now he's just showing some love for us I
wanted to show some love for you heck
yeah
absolutely shout out to Padre Tyler's
brother yo Tyler's
brother
yo that's
hilarious yeah we got 680 people W their
digital hands still strong man still
going uh oh I missed Jay's Super Chat
earlier
oh you did yeah I'm scrolling up and
it's gone I'm so
sorry but I'm glad I saw you here dude
um thanks Jay I appreciate you man I'm
sorry I'm doing I'm doing the best I
can Tila thanks man it's been a good
stream I agree minus my my uh my dubbed
audio all right all right I think my
animation is starting to get pretty
close I even got like a little bit of a
little bump little bouncy little bouncy
action all right I'm on
you nice oh no oh
no see sometimes the problem with two
few key frames is that you don't have
enough control over specific moments in
time
what's the best way to deal with that do
you like cut it in half and make a key
frame within that
moment yeah if I need to I'll just make
another key frame but um
oh hold up all right we're back my my
airpod died I've been switching back and
forth as they die for
sure um let's
see
get some octane noise here I want to
give this grip tape a little bit more
bump texture
so I'm going to set uh I'm going to use
noise set the projection XYZ to uvw and
the
transform I always set my noise to 100
contrast so I can see what I'm doing
I'll right click and I'll solo the node
and maybe this needs to come
down whoa that's pretty cool though
transform
001 all right so this needs to get
really granular here um let's try doing
chips or maybe circular fish fish and
chips fish on
chips yeah that I mean I think that will
be kind
of I don't know if I scale this down
enough1 yeah there you go there's your
grip tape disable the
solo Oh that's looking good oh yeah you
like it dude I'm maximizing the stream
right now just a look at it yeah it's
uh it's coming along it's all about that
large it's like the large scale uh dirt
swads yeah yeah dude if you can get a
footprint in there oh my God oh my God
it's possible I do have footprint
um why did I just use that
I mean it looks good right now looks
good now no now you got me going dude oh
no I have to use a footprint
um dude Reed actually had like in the
original uh file he sent over he
included shoes really and they're like
almost the same exact shoes I wear one
Wheeling the Vans that's
cool his are blue mine are black
Footprints oh oh wait no that this is
this this is the
wrong this is the wrong uh mix material
I need to
do this one I believe yes this
one and
footprints that makes way more sense
yeah it's just Footprints
instead
sweet yeah Ren look at it
now like on the
back oh wait God dang it my freaking
thing got paused
again yeah it totally looks
nice I like yeah there you go like that
yeah dude I I think the the last thing
that's really needed is getting some
scuff marks on that tire agreed I don't
know I don't know how agreed yeah I know
that um Ash Thorp on Instagram
posts some like really really nice car
renders and he has this render of like a
blue car shot from the back and you can
see this like fat tire and it has like
rocks and stuff stuck into it and it
looks so good yeah um that's definitely
the move I feel like I want to do
something like that but let me take a
look at my reference
here yeah so it's kind of like grayed
out the tire because of all of the dirt
dirt in it you know um and I feel like
this part of the tire is more rough than
the outside which is a bit shinier so
yeah a little glossier yeah I think I
need to get that going and get some dirt
and get some scratch in here um I think
using a bump map like a really sharp
bump map with pieces to like emulate
rocks being pushed into
it so that's my next goal back at
it I want to find a
better I'm just going to use a
sunlight I think that's going to be
easier to see my
scene I'm going to pour myself some more
coffee I'll be right back yeah sounds
good all right all right let's um let's
mix it with an hdri as
well Ren's whispering in my ear from the
kitchen that's ridiculous all
right three beers Ren I don't think I
have any any beero on me I
Wish uhoh R out of coffee
coffee oh let's see let's get another
hdri there we go that's nice I like
that all right so let's um isolate
this tire texture here so I'm going to
select the
material oh and it's already all
selected
fantastic so let's go ahead and
let's find our
original
material uh low plastic I think double
check this tire
copy this is what we want the wheel so
let's duplicate the
wheel and we'll drop it onto our
wheel and let's get to town let's dirty
this thing up let's move in
here and it looks like we we got a
diffuse pass we got a roughness pass and
a normal pass cool all right let's just
try doing some stuff with the bump real
quick so I'm going to do an octane noise
here which I can never come
on M
B oh not noise I need octane noise it's
over here on the left octane noise boom
drag it into the
bump and let's mess with with the
projection you can see it looks a little
warpy so if I set it to 100 you can see
it's being that's actually not that bad
let's take what what was
that are you are you looking at the bump
Channel yeah let's scale it down and
let's go to like chips and invert
it and like
that that's looking good yeah dude
that's the vibe that's looking good and
you know you can probably do oh Next
Level Next Level here's what you do you
take this noise control drag it up
here and
you oh wait okay next level hold on hold
on here's what you do you mix material
dude check this out you mix mix material
between the diffused
Channel wait wait bear with me you
mix between the diffuse Channel and an
RGB so the RGB is going to be like our
rocks imagine this is our
rocks um come on RGB spectrum and this
will be like a kind of a grayish light
gray and you're going to split up these
two textures this RGB and this image
texture with the noise the same
noise and it's the inverse of what we
want so we'll invert it again now we
have a bunch of rocks stuck into our
wheel but that doesn't look right so we
need to Crunch the gamma
down so now it looks like there's little
Pebbles stuck in our one
wheel and let's see if we can't crunch
this down this bump so like 1.2 oh my
God I just figured it out what did you
find the zoom did you figure out a
zoom yeah the zoom thing check this out
real yeah all right what you got so so
they're having me close out the dope
sheet before so like um if I don't do
that let's say I have this uh this key
frame here and I put it out of view I've
got no way to select it again right and
if I close out of the dope sheet and
come back nothing changed yeah but if I
scroll over here to the side where all
this stuff is and I just make that
smaller and bring it back there it is oh
snap okay that's a good if I lower that
down to something more reasonable close
that bring it back it scales
automatically to your key frames
whenever you open up the graph so even
though I can't like I can make this big
here uh if I put this something like a
little closer to there then
uh yeah I guess it'll be the maximum so
it's 400 down here but if I was to put
this up here and then this down there
then close out and come back it okay
it's the same I mean that that that
that's a nice little trick that's
totally like a nice little hack to get
that to work I wonder if there's a way
you can still zoom and stuff on it but
like that's perfect that's exactly what
you're looking for yeah that that that's
pretty much what I was looking for for
sure my goodness D we're back up to 700
people live we've been consistent man
for real
yeah yeah super sick all right so Ren
show show show everybody where you're at
right now and what your plans are um to
wrap out your
scene all right so my plan so this is
where I'm at
currently
I still got to fix the animation here at
the end but the idea is that I just have
this one animation of the the one wheel
coming in and then at the last moment
tail scrape and I think I'm going to
change the timing of that tail scrape to
be a little
later right now I have a pretty long
leadup of dragon the tail so I might try
to make that a little sooner but anyway
kind of the plan that I've got going
here is that uh I think this will it'll
probably be an angle kind of like this
where uh maybe I have a camera and it's
just constantly uh kind of moving you
know
forward like this and I'm just
duplicating this plane and offsetting it
off to the side and over so it's
something maybe like like you
know this perhaps sweet yeah oh and it
goes up you know something like cool
yeah so that like it's just a constant
like so we see this guy come flying in
uh
then and then uh it continues off and so
it keeps going uh it's just the one
curve here and then camera just keeps
slowly moving this way as the next one
comes up so it's just a way of basically
duplicating this one shot over and over
again uh so that we get that Loop you
know what you should do is um well this
is this is up to you but like if you
made it like a skate park texture where
it's like the the wood like the glossy
wood skate park texture and then you
have had like a like a metal little like
pop thing on the curb so it just looks
like yeah so it looks like you're at the
skate park you know like that could be
interesting not bad otherwise like yeah
I don't know I was I was picturing just
like a sidewalk material and then like
maybe some sort of like colored curb I
was even thinking of like Photo scanning
a real curb and using that but be sick I
don't know I don't know we're just Mega
scans all right um
sweet so yeah keep going on that I'm
almost done here on my one wheel um I'm
basically what I'm doing is like making
the onewheel model look really
nice um so I'm working on getting these
rocks in the tires right now
um how are we going to shift your
textures over to here I'll just I'll
just send you the pack and you'll just
have to reink you'll have to relink some
stuff but okay yeah cuz you're still
using like the actual textures that are
currently applied right yeah I am it's
just additional like for the
imperfections and
stuff sweet yeah that totally works for
the rocks that is super cool I like that
a
lot it's a good looking Tire yeah that's
that's actually a very realistic looking
Tire like that's exactly what my tire
looks like with all the pock marks from
the yes it's it's the pock marks yeah
exactly that's what it is it's like oh
mine's treaded so it's not exactly
a same sort of look
but yeah cuz over time you get little
like little divots just literally carved
out of the tire
yeah so I think what I'm going to do now
is it's like pretty shiny I'm going to
actually dirty it
up
um because it needs it desperately
oh someone's commenting on the hairline
in the middle of the tire uh and that's
just what the actual Tire looks like
fresh out of the box it's got a
seam
uh the only way I'd be able to get rid
of that is to go into the actual like
Photoshop texture the actual texture map
yeah I don't think it's a big deal it's
one of those things that gets worn down
over time but yeah agreed I think it I
think it's fine
agreed um that is looking really cool so
maybe what I'm going to do here is
actually use another dirt node so let's
get rid of that let's pipe in a dirt
node and we'll solo
it and I'll crank the strength just so I
can see what's going on and then I'll
crank the radius and I think that's
going based off of the
corners what's the best way to do this
yeah it's like the inverse of this is
what I
want so there's more dirt um let's see
if I can't go in here with a can I do
strength 20 no Max is at 10 so I'm going
to try and get this to be a bit more
black and white so I'll use an octane
gradient and just push these
values
um Mo what GPD G What GPU do I use I'm
on a Quadro RTX 6
,000 just one one old
GPU bless you pardon
me Lightning thank you for the Super
Chat man awesome awesome he says hi
Clinton Ren what advice can you give to
people thinking of freelance VFX CG
animation
online H freelancing VFX any advice Ren
No my only bit of advice would be to
check out Fiverr um you can probably
find some jobs on Fiverr uh just keep
following tutorials getting good getting
comfortable in the programs that you
have and uh yeah check out fivr also in
my Discord server there is a jobs
Channel sometimes people need stuff um
it's always paying uh and if it's not it
should be cuz it's work you should
definitely be paid for your work um and
yeah those are two options for
you all right I think this is probably
good
enough
yeah something like that
maybe
um o that's better there we go that's
what I
want that feels about right so the white
area or the gray area that's going to be
the area where you see the dirt the
black area is going to be the area where
there's no
dirt let's get rid of that not get rid
of it but we'll unpe it and then finally
we are going to cover this in
dirt so let's see here let's
uh let's throw another mixed material
down all right so let's pipe this this
material in this mix
material and let's throw another mix
material in between
it now what we want to do is we'll have
that be texture one and we'll have a
surface imp infection or you know what
we can do this with uh just noise so I'm
going to do an octane noise here uh
we'll drag it out from the
side into texture 2
projection will be XYZ to uvw and
transform we'll scale it down a little
bit
001 cool all right um let's take our
octaves well first off to see what we're
doing we'll give it the contrast and
we'll go a little higher here maybe
Point yeah that's not
bad let's go octaves
10 and Omega 1 and that's really going
to break it up nicely and we can set our
gamma a little bit higher something like
that and then we'll take our contrast
back down to a reasonable
number
something like that that's not bad okay
and then we're basically going to be
mixing between these two um
textures with this dirt map now we want
to color the dirt here like that that
same color that we were using for our
actual dirt texture so we can actually
reference this value 26
2948 26
2948 um let's bust out a gradient
26 29 I think
28 26
and then we'll do the same yeah we'll
just have it be one color
right and we'll mix between
it with the dirt node so right now we
have dirt in the middle of the wheel but
not on the sides that's exactly what we
want the M Cricut why isn't Ren using
Houdini right now well I don't know cuz
we're we're working in
cuz I don't know how to use Houdini I
literally just decided I'm going to
start learning it like two days ago the
the most I've done is sign up for a
course and download The Apprentice free
version Tom Baker you're out of date
with your
info Everything's changed in the last
couple days what does he
say Ren never uses Houdini as far as I
know which as of before two days ago
you're right
no I'm I'm going to try to figure out
how to use Houdini and see if I can use
that going forward cuz I think the thing
I like most in in CG stuff is
doing uh simulated stuff right like I
like Dynamics I like simulations um and
I want to be able to have more custom
control over those kind of things and so
I'm I'm going to see what I can do with
Houdini it's it's time it's just a very
intimidating dating program certainly
but I think it's time to give it a shot
I think it's smart though because you're
basically doing what Sam and Peter need
help with like Sam and Peter are in
unreal so your thought was like why be
the third person in unreal when I can be
the one guy in Houdini helping them
exactly yeah it's all about management
and like time management I I totally
agree I think that's a really smart
move all right that's a dirty
Tire sweet that's looking
nice looking nice all right maybe I mess
with the roughness a little
bit how shiny do we want this
wheel yeah feels pretty good to me
that's a dirty
wheel
heck yeah I think I'm going to chill out
the footprints just a little
bit let's
see is this the footprints yeah Power
point1
maybe so there's a little bit more
subtle and then I think I can scale them
down just a little bit
.04
sweet okay that looks really
good I'm feeling happy with this I think
the last thing I'm going to do to
texture this thing is to just grunge up
this this plastic here this dark gray
plastic it needs
work and that goes around the entire
board so I think I'm just going to dirty
it scratch it and call it it that so
let's go ahead and select all that stuff
I'm just going to select the polygons
that are touching the areas I know I
want to alter so this dark gray plastic
here um technically this is part of the
same object right up in
here and the this bumper right here you
might as well get the bottom because
even though you might not see the bottom
too much and it's going to be way
dirtier than the top I'll still select
it and I'm just going to hit uy a whole
bunch and that's going to grow our
selection and spread like wild
fire bam look at that now we have all
the stuff we want selected
that's a little trick for you is to
select just one or two of the polygons
on the areas that you want and grow the
selection with UI and it'll look
nice we got 730 people up in here right
now D yeah son it's growing it's
growing Ren how you doing man you
hanging
in I'm tired
man but yeah check it out if you want to
throw it back to my screen real quick
got a mostly final animation now um so
these are my these are my key frames
that I finally got all sorted out let's
see if I can compress this down a little
bit um but yeah
uh key frames am I
right but as you can see I've got like
these little I was pointing at my
monitor as if my screen recording could
catch that uh I've got these little
little bumps here so as it as the tail
drops it actually bounces back a little
and then over here when I climb the curb
I actually hop a little and bounce up
there so you can kind of see that if we
look
closely um so it
comes and then rinse and repeat so let's
see if I
actually get this down to like say
150 dude one more time yeah not quite a
little bit more
[Music]
sorry I'm getting like my balance set
correctly here all good
[Music]
sure that's great dude heck yeah I need
I it still needs a little bit more
tweaking I think think I'm going to
maybe have the
yeah that's nice dude that's really nice
it's it's very close it's very close I'm
going to tweak uh this a little I'm
going to make this slightly less sharp
let's see what that looks
like there we go that's pretty much what
I'm after dude that's so perfect
um that's really
good that's super good dude yeah that
looks really nice
with motion blur it's going to look
nice heck yeah all right so I love it
this is like yeah this is awesome do you
freaking this is great do you want to I
mean like wait what okay hold on one
more time not like like sure this might
be great eventually I don't know I'm
just saying like what we're doing you
know making stuff this is great like
this is cool like Cinema 4D man what it
allows us to create for from literally
nothing yeah is awesome agreed man
agreed like I I really like the fact
that it's a collab thing I've never done
a live collab uh before so I think um
all we have left to do I have one last
texture to work on do you want to maybe
see about cloning this and setting up a
camera move while I do my last texture
and then I'll send the stuff over to you
and okay I think from there I obviously
you're not going to have enough time to
render it but because you're going have
to like relink the textures I'll send
you the texture pack I'll see if I can
finish this up maybe either uh later
this evening or tomorrow maybe tomorrow
yeah whatever maybe post it Monday or
something could be sweet yeah post it
post it what post it um Iberian I see
you sorry for missing the Super Chat man
appreciate it he says hey just wanted to
say you guys are awesome and an
inspiration to me for my career into V
effects and
animation um also any tips for Cycles 4D
materials I don't know what Cycles 4D
materials are to be honest with you
Cycles like blender Cycles 4D I don't
know what that
is Cycles is a is a blender thing Cycles
is like a renderer yeah in BL in
blender um I don't know maybe Peter
Peter would have those answers Ian maybe
uh maybe blender Guru but yeah in c4d
these
days um but I appreciate you man with
the Super Chat sorry for missing you I
appreciate
it okay um oh Cycles 4D is the c4d
add-on for the Cycles
Render interesting yeah I don't know
about that Cycles
gross all right that's unfair that's
totally unfair yeah whatever whoever's
you know whatever tool works
so now right now the last thing I'm
trying to get right here is the sort of
the the animation coming out of the
thing the thing cuz it's like it's
starting to accelerate before the tire
like or the the board is like tipped
forward enough that makes
sense oh snap
KRON what a Super Chat man thank you he
says hi Ren hi Clint can I ask why don't
you use substance painter for this kind
of shading I love to uh create custom
shaders and chrona render but if I need
to do extra detailing I switch to
substance painter one simple answer I've
never used it before and I don't know
how to use
it but I would love to learn um I think
it could be really fun there's just a
lot of programs to learn you know a
whole bunch but man thank you for the
Super Chat yeah really cool there we go
now I'm getting something close let's
see it
dude that's so
good are you are you um nose
scraping little bit so starts with a
tail scrape and if we go into our side
view
here see it catches a little bit of air
a little bit Perfect Dude then that's so
good and then acces out that's play
it I'm I'm pretty pleased with this like
this is this is getting pretty close to
how an actual curb nudge looks in real
life is your tire spinning right now or
no I oh I haven't I haven't started
that well it's cuz the way I'm going to
do it is just by brute forcing the
animation so I have to make sure that
like I have a locked cut you know it's
like I have to to make sure my edit is
locked before I start VFX yeah it's like
I got to make sure my animation curves
for the whole board is set correctly
before I start animating the tire
spinning yeah that makes sense man
definitely or no no no no no no no no no
no how can I link the rotation of an
object to the linear
movement of a single axis son so like
that's like some uh uh what is it
espresso espresso what's what's it
called espresso espresso not the drink
uh uh I know the espresso scripting
stuff I think that's what it is yeah
dang man does anyone know how to do that
because it's like if I can just take
this one object here so I can freely I
can freely rotate this y like so uh
where's the key frame for that okay so
tire key frame which axis is this oh H
cool so if I go back to the beginning
that key
[Music]
frame okay so now I should have that
available
here um tire there we go boom got my key
frame
rotation which one is
it roll that one down
sweet okay so if I could find a way to
literally link this value using like
[Laughter]
pie oh God it's Advanced I know there's
a way I've done it before in 3ds Max I
animated a whole freaking bicycle for
Henry for minute
physics and you did this in c4d way back
then no I did it in 3ds Max got
you yeah there's a way to link it up I'm
going to check the chat real quick um
Tom Tom Moore thank you for the Super
Chat I appreciate you man super sick uh
you guys are really popping off here
with the super chats me and R are going
to get a nice dinner together I promise
um he says Hey guys love the stuff any
chance of an X particles or real flow
tutorial in the future um real flow yeah
maybe I don't know like I I had X
particles for a while um I really loved
it I need to update my license but um I
think Ren is actually well here's the
thing Ren can we say anything
about
um the God dang okay what what's the
like volumetric real time Ember genen
Ember genen Ember yeah yeah what about
oh uh oh their their programs that
they're going to announce hopefully at
the end of this year we probably
shouldn't uh they yeah I mean yeah cool
things ahead
yeah I mean I don't know if it's
spoiling anything it's like if you're on
their Discord you know all about it but
it's like yeah it's um yeah I don't I'm
not going they're working on a on a
liquid they're a liquid solution right
uh yeah that cool it's it's it's like
not I asked him I was like hey what's
the like timeline on this program like
are we talking a week a month a year and
they're like H closer to a year than a
month so yeah they're hoping that maybe
by the end of this year they'll have
something to kind of like announce so
like awesome I me they're priority right
now is entirely on imen yeah uh which is
I think the right move to make uh it's
it's imen is so cool see that's the main
thing is that
like I also want to get back into imin
for all my like fire and smoke needs
because it's so good at rendering stuff
quickly it allows you to iterate so much
quicker than you could in say fume
effects fume effects uh was the fire and
smoke simulation of choice for me back
in the day uh worked in 3ds Max did a
whole bunch of smoke stuff but you'd
like you'd mess with some settings and
hit simulate and you'd wait for it to
play out before you could decide yeah
this isn't what I'm going for go back
change some more settings let it play
out and then be like that's closer but
not still what I'm going for it's it's
that process of iteration you play
change settings play again change more
settings until you start narrowing in on
what you're trying to go for with emen
because it stimulates essentially in
real time it's so much quicker and it's
like it allows I mean yeah the rendering
is quick and on you hit render and it's
it's like almost done that's cool but
that's not the thing that excites me
most is being able to actually see the
results in real time as you're changing
settings it allows you to identify what
is working and what isn't working way
faster and so it allows you to dial in
your final look really quickly yeah
there just more room for play and
creation versus uh waiting around for
the answer you
know yeah yeah yeah imen is really cool
I want to do some stuff with emgen I
think it'd be
amazing dude
oh I'm gonna have to have I'm G to have
a smoke Sim in this in this post I have
to I thought you I thought you just said
I'm going to take a smoke break like for
that's where my mind went to I was like
you smoke cigar I had the other night
yeah where did that come from I just I
don't know I was I was riding with uh
Jan on one Wheels like a week ago and he
happened to have a cigar on the ride and
it inspired me cuz I like I don't smoke
at all but I'll Have a Cigar every now
and then my dad likes to smoke cigars so
whenever I'm like visiting him and I
will like sit down and have like a
little bit of whiskey and or some scotch
and a cigar that's cool and I enjoy that
uh so I was like you know what I was at
I was at a liquor store buying uh some
beer and right next to the the cash
register was like a box of cigars and I
was like H grab one and put it on the
the sixpack of beer I was like all right
I'm going to get it and so then that
night I was repairing uh Nico's one
wheel I
uh I I I smoked that cigar I smoked half
of it before I like oh I'm getting sick
those cigar
teeth yeah good times yeah cigars Good
Times um man more Super chats you guys
are awesome uh cillo says by the way
Clint to help Ren realism you could try
add the displacement on the wheel
material so that when it crosses an
object it'll create a squeeze from the
impact by some distance Mas you guys
think these one Wheels tires squish a
lot more than they actually
do that sounds that sounds like a lot
dude that sounds like a lot I think this
is going to work just perfect for what
Ren's going for um especially like the
the camera perspective I want to have
here you're not even going to be able to
see the the tire deformation technically
the tire does flatten a little bit just
a little bit uh on the contact with the
ground and it will deflect a little bit
when you hit bumps and rocks and and
yeah definitely the curb but the curb
doesn't have all of your weight pressing
down on it the idea is that you don't
have any of your weight on the tire when
you actually do the the curb nudge so
it's in theory not going to deflect at
all other than you know just the
straight down and I thought about doing
some sort of like uh deformer like a
mograph deformer like a proximity based
thing so that kind of like squishes up
the closer it gets to a surface but the
problem is that if I do that that's
going to change the all of the
animations I just did for the rotation
because it's like if the wheel goes up a
little bit the back of the board would
have to be compensated by lifting up a
little bit as well and that's going to
adjust the rotation just a little bit
and I already have that all dialed in so
I don't think that's something I I want
to try to incorporate for something
that's like something that even if I was
to do it you probably still wouldn't
notice it because it won't be visible
yeah for
sure and my my my goal with this is to
make it as realistic as possible so like
we're talking photo realism Clint that's
in your court you're making that happen
I'm trying to get the animation as
realistic as possible because it's like
this is a maneuver I do all the time on
my one whe I'm fairly familiar with it
and I want to have like I want to have
that realism of just like this is how it
works absolutely uh technically I am
missing that little bit of Tire
deflection but I don't think it'll even
be visible in camera so I'm not worri
about it yeah yeah it's it's it's really
like how you spend your time you want to
spend your time on like yeah the the the
the biggest stuff first and then you
know you kind of Branch out from there
yeah a couple people have already
mentioned that technically under a
normal load a tire deforms
15% uh of the taus small diameter it's
like cool uh I think that's for a bike I
think it's a little different on a
go-kart Tire
uh crazy cuz the overall diameter is a
lot smaller um I think the deflection
maybe I don't know I don't know enough
it's just not something I'm going to
tackle for sure yeah it's not worth it
you know there's already so much to
do oh and I will definitely be around
around for the weekly submission contest
I I'll stick it out heck yeah sweet yeah
we'll get to that soon I'm I'm almost
done with my material and then I think
I'll I will
probably I think what I'll
do since we still have like a lot of
work to do on this I'll probably send
you this after our stream and then you
can wrap it up on your own time and you
guys will probably see this on on Ren's
Instagram uh probably like next week or
something I don't know does that sound
right maybe maybe tomorrow maybe
tomorrow sweet yeah um maybe Monday I do
want to get some sound design for it
though so oh did you see render token
freaking tweeted out this stream
really yeah
dude heck yeah heck yeah dude that's
like Daffy and uh and Carlos and
everybody like they're all they're all
up in there that's
awesome they they tweeted out a couple
hours ago that's probably when Daffy
I've not been on my phone so I haven't
seen any of this that's so sick um you
got to give some more shout outs here
more Super chats uh so Tom Moore says do
you see o toys realtime renderer for
octane Bri Brigade it looks insane um
yeah I'm very very excited for that it's
going to be sick um and David Turk says
help me Obi Ren Kenobi you're my only
hope is Ren sticking around for the
weekly submission contest you know Ren
already answered that question and uh I
think the answer is uh it's it's the
good version of that answer yes he will
he'll be around he literally just said
it sorry I'm I'm catching up on this and
Hunter Williams um fxd for uh for
feature here if you ever want to talk
about Graphics simulations love y'all
stuff what you do in the community rock
on sweet heck yeah dang man I just you
want to talk about bfxr react for a
moment
yeah so we do this show called VFX RS
react uh it's really fun to do and we'll
sit on this couch and and talk for like
2 or 3 hours about all these cool
effects and then that gets edited down
to 15 minutes give or take a couple
minutes right I think uh the the Harry
Potter one that went out today was like
19 minutes or something like that um so
I got a tweet from this dude named uh
Wiis
ridiculous that's
ridiculous uh basically saying hey heads
up I gave you a comment on the video my
whole online persona based on the
Wizarding World you need to do serious
black in the fireplace uh talking from
the fireplace both times and I'm like
wait we did that we did that we totally
did that we totally talked about the the
whole series Black talking from the
fireplace I'm like but I don't recall
seeing it in the video it didn't make
the
cut that's how it goes sometimes so it's
like that H that's that's indicative of
like a lot of things that happen with
the show is that like we'll actually say
something we'll talk about something and
then it just doesn't make it into the
edit and then you get commenters being
like why didn't you talk about that oh
you should have talk about this oh the
fact that they didn't mention this one
thing here means they don't actually
know what's going on and it's like in
truth we did know what's going on and we
did mention it it just didn't make it
into the video so people have like this
weird warp perception that like 100% of
that video it's like they think that our
videos are like recorded in real time
and if we didn't say it on in the final
product we didn't say it at all yeah
which makes sense
it gets confusing frustrating sometimes
it's like we did talk about it no it
gets confusing because we'll we'll also
it's a clarifications well it's just
like did we talk about that and we'll be
like I swore we talk about that but then
it's not in the video and we're like I
just completely forgot if we talked
about it or not I remember talking about
it but
like uh it didn't get edited in so w we
we can't do it again because we don't
know if it got edited or not and this
happens like we've done how many of
these like almost 35 40 maybe more we're
coming up on two years Just sh I have
two years that's insane of not missing a
single week so we're at about a 100
episodes now that's
insane
yeah um that's like some of my favorite
stuff is sitting down with you guys and
just talking about VFX or you know
stunts yeah man it's so much
fun um all right let's wrap this up and
let's get to these winners um I'm yeah
sounds good to me I'm basically finished
with my guy here uh it's looking pretty
good I just need
to take this like gray texture and tone
it down this like this bit here it's too
much so I need to find it and tone it
down but you know what I can do that
later that's that's no fun this is what
we're looking at though it's like a a
dirty one
wheel and wait can you have like more of
a background on that thing it's kind of
hard to see with the black background
okay cool yeah um let's do like turn on
turn on HD
totally let's do like
a octane Shadow catcher
material and maybe
nice see that's looking good that is a
that is a used one whee yeah yeah man I
feel good about it the foot pads are
really nice um the scratch textures are
nice I just need to tone down the
scratch on the side it's too bright but
I'll I'll I'll do that later when I send
it over to you um and yeah the inside of
the wheel weld is looking like really
nice too it's all dirty and stuff
mhm wait flip it around to the other
side so we can see it from the sunlight
side oh there's this piece that's I
think the material is not connected on
this bit interesting so the plastic the
so the metal rail uh scratch marks look
fantastic but the plastic above it I'm
not sure would be uh that scratchable or
it would look like that scratched do you
know oh 100% agreed yeah
100% um let me load
this yep I agree with you on that can
bring that down that would be I'm just
getting confused I have so many mixed
materials here I'm like where oh yeah
for sure which one is
which yeah that would just be me taking
the power down of
that maybe set that to like two
gamma and scale it down a little
bit maybe even switch it out for another
one of these scratched textures
I just got to relink all this
stuff and take down the brightness of
this scratch right
here I don't know
why where is
it
here's here's a question
yeah I lost it hold up wait okay there
it is Ben snow asks wait did Peter get
to keep the Puget engine or is that just
a sign to whoever wins those contests
hey you guys want to hear a dirty secret
all of the the the prizes for these
render competitions are never real no
never Sam winning the computer back
guess who's still using that computer
Peter yep
uh that computer went to Peter it was
coincidental that he won that computer
and then also got to keep using that
computer it just he needed a computer he
happened to be the one who was going to
receive that computer he also happened
to win that competition uh yeah but Sam
winning that computer back that was just
that was just drama that was just Stakes
for the for the the scene totally you
know it's
like
uh we're getting some new pits though
we're going to be getting some more 309s
in the studio which would be great
um I don't want to talk about the mega
workstation just yet that one's a
special one but who knows if that'll
happen um that one's still probably
month or two away but yeah uh I think
I'm probably the next in line for a new
computer I think I will probably get one
of these new ones so I'll probably have
a 3090 at the studio again that would be
sweet or at the studio I have a 3090
here at home which is very nice I like
this computer very much Puget um hooked
you up yeah it did indeed yeah Puget is
so so awesome I love them so much
they're they're really cool people they
really know how to make computers uh to
what you want a computer to be this is
kind of turning into a bit of a Puget
push I don't intentionally I don't
intend that I'm
sorry this isn't my stream oh but
they're legit they're legit they're
legit I like them they're they're good
people every time we've gone to NAB
we've always like hung out with them uh
shout out to Eric and uh the rest of the
crew all right um Ren so I guess I'll
send this over to you uh after the
stream here that looks great and that
looks great yeah you'll you'll bring it
to you know final till it's final form
and then you guys can check the final
render on Ren's
Instagram um you know pretty soon
here but uh but yeah oh I totally forgot
uh my intention with the the smoke
simulation earlier cuz you thought I was
going on a smoke break then we talk
about cigars oh for sure
yeah uh when the tail drag I want to
have like dust fly out from it
like dude yes that'd be perfect maybe
have a bit of a a little smoke SIM for
that I don't know that's that's starting
to get into the territory of like that's
a lot of effort yeah but I know maybe
maybe this could be uh maybe this could
be something that you put a lot of
effort into for the sake of it being a
big thing to drop at some point who
knows maybe I don't know dude yeah you
dude yes Ren which is you got get that
submission going son I know that's
that's a priority for me this weekend
I'm going to get my submission to super
rare for sure all right last little
shout outs here for all y'all super
chatting Zach um I see you thank you for
your support I appreciate you Tom once
again thank you so much uh he says you
do VFX Tian for three hours and we only
get 15 minutes I've never been so upset
don't worry you get the best of it I
promise um yeah yeah and and Zack uh did
you Watch Attack on Titan trailer in
Corridor Reddit I I know Ren's all about
Attack on Titan dude Attack on Titan
it's it's me Nico Christian and Matt
we're all like super into Attack on
Titan right now because the fourth
season's happening and it's so good it's
so good I don't know if you're talking
about a specific trailer in in our
subreddit but uh yeah Tech on Titan in
general is pretty awesome I've only seen
season
one it's a good show it's a good show
all right guys D I feel like camera is
just like smeared with
Vaseline except for your face yeah
that's hilarious um all right so here's
what we're going to do I'm going to take
a five minute break here okay guys Ren
and I are going to decide the winners
and we're going to come back at you with
the um the weekly challenge winners
there's going to be five of them and
then I got some honorable mentions for
everybody so stay tuned all right guys
we'll be back 5 minutes don't don't go
anywhere maybe grab a a water or a snack
or something but we'll see you guys soon
[Music]
peace
for
[Music]
all right
everybody we're back we're going to do
it we um have talked about it we've
picked our
winners um it's very difficult to do
because there's a lot of really really
nice
renders um so
yeah uh let's see here let me switch off
a studio mode here we go so I can see
things a little bit better in OBS all
right
y'all thanks for hanging out with us we
got 581 of y'all up in here um we're
doing the weekly challenge reviews all
right so the challenge last week was or
technically this week was Star Wars you
guys had to render your best Star Wars
image uh and whatever program you wanted
um it had to be original enough you know
you can download models here and there
but you know you really need to make a
the scene your own every week we do this
so at the end of this review we're going
to be announcing the new challenge um
for this week or for this next week but
yeah let's um let's get into it guys the
first winner of the Star Wars weekly
challenge is none other than
Mr visual himself with this incredible
Millennium Falcon this thing is rid
ridiculous it's so good like the color
colors everything about this the colors
the textures the contrast contrast
yeah like I wish I could see a little
bit more detail in the shadow of like
the dish and underneath the the cape
it's just pure black yeah but it's like
but I love it yeah it's stylized um it's
freaking incredible so Ren I don't know
if you remember but um during the the
render Montage that I did visual he was
the guy who did the one of like the uh
the Monk walking through with all the
flags and then this giant snake in the
background oh yeah yeah same guy yeah I
do remember that one same dude I
remember the snake specifically yeah um
cypo what's up dude um thank you for the
Super Chat he says what a combo it a
great stream I really enjoy just
listening to your guys' stories about
VFX also there was the talk about making
it easier for you to choose um the
winners wait what also there was the
talk about making it easier for for you
to choose the winners oh I'm a little
confused um yeah I don't know what that
means but cypo thanks dude um and if you
guys don't know cypo is the guy who make
the render clock on the Discord so
you'll see a countdown however many days
hours you have left to get your render
in that's cypo so thanks dude all right
um number according to Ben langon I'm
too
loud no you're good you're you're mixed
I got you mixed um I think he meant my
personality oh that's nonsense no I
don't know I don't know I'm just
guessing I'm just sorry I interrupted
you please continue number two y'all
number two the second winner of the Star
Wars weekly challenge this
week
is moonshake 3D with this render right
here it is a perfect render of R2-D2 um
oh that's the R2 you're talking about
that looks great it's
insane like the freaking quality on this
is ridiculous it looks photo real you
could make a short film and out of this
right now and it would look photo real
your your imperfections are perfect it's
ridiculous I love I love the the
reflections of the light panels up above
yes yes like they look like Star Wars
light panels yep it's beautiful man
absolutely fantastic work and you
actually have a second render that I'm
going to talk about in the honorable
mentions I got about 20 of you guys in
the honorable mentions here um that I
want to show off we'll get to that after
we get through our five winners so
congratulations to moonshake 3D you got
the challenge winner roll this week wear
it proud all right and keep rendering
stuff to hold on to it next
week all right number three guys who do
we have for number three perfect
imperfections boom deare Mudan with the
freaking Wand Shop dude yeah the saber
shop Saber shop
this is hand modeled by him everything
is hand modeled by him this is insane
dang man yeah who uh I forget the race
of those
um the that the the freaking gecko
people the I forget their the race name
yeah it's insane like your Lighting on
this is really good your your color is
fantastic um you're telling a story you
got some the mon calamari that's it mon
calamari that's great
yeah this is incredible the vibe is nice
he's just chilling straight up chilling
like it's a Tuesday no one wants to buy
lightsabers on Tuesday God dang it why
am I even clocked in right now or he
just sold like he sold a bunch of
lightsabers and he's like dude I could
retire right
now he's like this was a good day
several young Jedi came in features
looking
bright so that's awesome congratulations
dear Mudan for winning the challenge
this week hang on to it all right you
got the challenge winner roll for this
week all right two more and then we get
into the honorable mentions and we'll
wrap it out so let's
do bam and the fourth winner of the
weekly
challenge this week is m o K2 I think
that's your name I think that's your
full name MCH 2 Mack
2D2 oh this is a k2so k2so what's oh is
k2so the
robot yeah oh okay well then I guess MO
is your
name yeah um anyway this is this is
awesome I love this like it's such a
chill little scene um it's a different
take on the Star Wars Vibe which I
really like a lot I love your color
those freaking sandals yeah yeah the
Japanese like wood
sandals it's freaking great dude yeah I
burst out laughing as well the colors
are sick I love the clouds in the
background you got that really nice like
puffy cloud look so the actor who played
this robot in the movie is the same
actor who did uh the robot from iroot
really yeah oh that's sick wait I Robot
that's the one with Will Smith right
that's okay I got the name right cool
yeah uh I'm blanking on his name he's
been a lot of cool stuff Firefly
Serenity um that's sick yeah that's
awesome um and yeah dude this uh I don't
know if you've ever played Tekken but
this definitely gives me Yoshi mitsu
vibes that's it oh the actor some Tekken
Vibes it's cuz the Hat yeah the actor's
name is uh Alan tudk nice uh yeah do
that hat that little like Vietnamese sun
shade hat yeah I love it it's freaking
awesome oh my God speaking of Vietnamese
so I I watched the rated R video and
when I'm like doing the map I know
exactly what you're talking
about there's a moment there where I
talk about I I miss being better than
everyone at basketball and dunking in
all the little Vietnamese children and
it's like that moment is just left
completely out of
context yeah cuz most people like don't
know you went to school in
Vietnam yeah
dude I I played high school basketball
in Vietnam and I because I was taller
than pretty much everyone else I was
better dude that's so funny I laughed
out loud when I when I when I took that
out of context CU obviously like I knew
I knew yeah but like if no one knows the
context they just going to be like wait
what excuse me that was
oh man so good all right um we got one
more winner so let's see it
congratulations you got the challenge
winner roll um last but not least now
this was very difficult to choose there
was so many good ones again over the
last
month over the what are you
saying don't worry about
it well you can't just be saying that
stuff dude what are you saying don't
worry about it you
know all right
anyway the fifth winner bam here we go
toab with this beautiful scene of the
desert of Luke's home I assume this is
Luke's Home whoa that's a render
yeah yeah wow all right yeah that's uh
that's on Tatooine all right it's
freaking perfect dude the colors are
ridiculous the lighting is perfect
it looks like a scene from the movie um
absolutely incredible so toab
congratulations for
winning this week's challenge the Star
Wars challenge guys um so you all get
the challenge winner roll if you guys
want to get the challenge winner roll
you got to win the weekly challenge and
to win the weekly challenge you got to
participate in the weekly challenge and
make something sick um so
congratulations to you guys I want to
get into some honorable mentions so
let's just go through these and and give
some some fun shout outs here um
so let's start with this is moonshake
this is a winner but um he did a second
one which I thought was sick Moon shake
and this is like the the actual set View
and this how they did it they have this
little trap door on the right and the
the puppeteers come out from this hole
in the ground and they move the uh this
what is it the at Walker what's it
called wait hold up wait you're telling
me this is a render this is like very
photorealistic this looks exactly like
the set that they made for this yeah
yeah it's beautiful what the heck man
that looks amazing yeah it's incredible
absolutely incredible this is the guy
who rendered the
r21 right okay the AT-AT so that's
freaking sick um absolutely incredible
dude Samu Ginder thank you for the Super
Chat he says if only I knew earlier Ren
was coming I would have tried harder to
fix my PC for the weekly challenge but
hey at least uh oh at least now I can
say hi to Ren myself so hey Ren yeah
what's up Samu yeah dude
that's
awesome all right um Jason born Vita
with this awesome Mandalorian uh like
trailer poster looks amazing photo real
absolutely incredible um I think it
looks freaking
awesome what else we got we got Alpha
code with this cool render here of this
uh Mountain thing um waa dude that's
cool yeah it's really sick I'm getting
some stor vibes from it yeah yeah it's
really nice um really really good job on
the render there let's see Yoshi with
the X-Wing looks really cool I love the
model I love the planet you got I think
it is super solid and it's a nice little
scene you got oh I saw this one yeah
yeah got that atmosphere down so this
guy RS did these two images here that
are very painly and I love them a lot I
think they're really cool like desktop
backgrounds yeah these are sick um so
R's shout outs man really cool uh Izzy
thank you for the Super Chat you say I
mainly just want to know how Ren ended
up in Vietnam also keep up the good
work it's a long
story you don't want to go into it I
mean not really my I moved there in high
school my my dad was working with the
the government and stuff and then you
had to move yeah had to mooved to
Vietnam um Willie you're next Will's
always either winning or making the
honorable mentions but Willie is 14 uses
blender and puts out work like this it's
incredible holy crap yeah
seriously seriously man blender is great
for young kids because it's like it's
free you know kids don't have money but
they might want to get into like 3D
stuff so you know blender's number one
like uh feater is its price it's free
and the fact that it's as powerful as it
is for free is insane I mean that's how
Peter got started he was like 12 years
old and he's like oh I'm going to learn
this 3D program cuz I it's free and I
don't have any money and then you know
10 years later he's working at Corridor
and his freaking kicking out freaking
basketball Harry Potter yeah seriously
that dude that scene is so funny oh my
God so good if you guys hadn't seen the
rated R Harry Potter um does it come out
tomorrow or is it out today it's coming
out tomorrow unless you're on the
website in which case you can go watch
it right now very true very very true
cordor digital.com right MH all right um
next up honorable mentions we got Val
with this Lego render of Vader walking
down the hallway this is awesome very
very close to being a winner um yeah
that that one's cool all of these are
freaking love the ground yeah the ground
is sick the surface imperfections are on
point um Tai rimmed Ty rimmed is that
your full name Ty rimmed
edited um or maybe that's just the name
of the file who knows but I love it I
love the red like it almost looks like
Japanese text in the background um I
think it's really cool so shout outs to
whoever made
this um next up we got this render here
these models are crazy I don't know if
you downloaded them or if you model them
yourself but you're lighting your space
lighting is on point your planet looks
really good
too um what what else what else soski
with this cool render I really like the
atmosphere I like the lighting I think
you did a good job here and the color is
pretty sweet
too snowman yeah that one's cool dude
yeah going through the like the freaking
like atmosphere super sick we have this
one by snowman this is the the
multicolored renders you were talking
about Ren like the phone backgrounds
yeah I like those ones they're really
cool color and silhouette I love a good
silhouette same composition there is
very nice yep yeah it looks really good
so shout outs to uh snowman second
sister oh wait no this is
Natalie she hand modeled a oh yeah yeah
this is cool she hand modeled this
lightsaber INF Fusion 360 and like you
can actually she provided provides the
file in the submission channel on
Discord you can actually pull up the
file and do the exploded view and see
all the parts that went into it it's
it's it's a perfect handcrafted piece of
uh I don't know this is meant to be
printed like this is literally meant to
be like like downloaded and 3D printed
you can print all the different parts
and assemble it into what you're looking
at yeah yeah it's super sick gron she
threw on some materials onest it's like
nice and shiny if you were to print it
it won't be nice and shiny but yeah I
think that's just incredible hand
modeled um she's really good at Fusion I
want to get good yeah yeah she's better
than I am for sure uh render trap with
this one you came so close to winning
it looks super good man um yeah it's an
incredible render yeah I saw that one
too yep it's really nice it's a really
really nice render um everything's great
you know your your camera angle your
lighting all that stuff maybe I think
you could use a little fog but that's
just me you know I'm always about the
fog I feel like I want to see baby
Yoda's face I I think I get what he's
getting for he's like trying to get
Mando's attention but like I think the
image would be a little better if we
could see his eyes I agree if like baby
Yoda was looking at something that got
his attention but was like pulling his
arm but still looking at what got his
attention off camera or something yeah
yeah yeah um and then the but then again
maybe the the model is kind of Jank so
he's kind of like hiding hiding the
flaws of it I don't know I don't know
yeah I could see that too definitely but
yeah render trap good job those sick uh
one yeah I like one dead duck with this
one looks really cool um nice little
faceof moment here uh you got some
Ships coming at this character it's
going to be an epic
battle that was a fun one noodle
Chan with uh I don't know what is this
called Sky City what's what's the name
of it freaking Cloud City Cloud City
yeah that's a sick render very nice yeah
that's pretty sweet very beautiful dude
we could turn Cloud we could do we could
actually do Cloud City on Venus I wanted
to make a video talking about how we can
have uh civilization it'd be easier to
have a civilization on Venus than it
would be on Mars really yeah maybe I'll
make a video on it Venus is second from
the
Sun yeah so it's a lot closer to the Sun
uh they had a whole
like yeah their environment
sucks yeah that's I mean I could only
imagine any other planet environment
just being
rough yeah it's uh we sent a Rover there
the Russians sent a Rover there a couple
decades AO go and it managed to snap two
pictures before the Rover melted
jeez it's so hot it's like 800° on the
surface of Venus oh my God yeah there
they had access to the it's not a Rover
it was like a a module satellite that
landed on the ground like they had
access to it for like less than an hour
that's insane can you like are those
pictures online
somewhere yeah that's cool that's super
cool um all right we got like three more
and then we'll wrap put up here guys uh
Noah with this cool render here of the
forest I don't know the name is it at
freaking Walker thing I don't know the
name of it oh that's cool yeah contrasty
directional lighting yeah I like it a
lot very nice then we got Nate with one
of my favorite movies of all time Space
Balls
um oh yeah I know this one this scene is
when he's like wait is it now now when
did win was now he's like just then we
missed it just then freaking great oh I
just realized that's supposed to be uh
what's his face Harrison Ford on the
right Harrison Ford on the right isn't
it looks like Harrison Ford no no it's
um definitely not that's Colonel
Sanders
what not really but that's his
name I mean it looks like Harrison Ford
to
me I mean obviously Rand on the left but
I love it I thought that was a good one
um and then last but not least honorable
mention we got Mr
ant um Commando maybe
cmdo um you keep getting better and
better man you're sending me all of your
renders that's cool yeah you're sending
me all of your renders on Discord and
like you keep getting better and better
so keep up the good work man I think
it's really
sick
Ren that's it dude
that's all of
it dang sorry David Turk which one was
yours he's bum he didn't make the cut
yeah I'm sorry it's hard to get to them
all guys we had a lot to set up um Tech
wise this morning so we couldn't get to
everything but we did our best I
appreciate you guys thanks for hanging
out Bradley thanks for the Super Chat he
says Ren I sent you a message on
Instagram regarding solar energy in your
next video oh my god dude I get so many
messages I don't I'm sorry if I missed
it I think he just sent it
probably anyway uh Ren let's figure out
what the next weekly challenge is right
now we have uh two ideas we have low
poly and we have giant those are two
prompts that are up in the
air
um I'm also open to any other ideas that
you might have Ren but low poly I like
the idea of low poly yeah uh like a cool
like low poly vibe I think I mean maybe
yeah no I dig that low poly that's
that's the that's the thing low poly it
is giant you could do another time all
right but I want to see low poly
whatever that means maybe it's some like
ambient occlusion type art where it's
all super simple diffuse shaders uh or
maybe like do a twist on it where it's
like you have some really incredible
like Greenery and and and stuff in a
scene really high resed stuff all around
like the super low poly object whatever
it is yes uh I don't know there's this
girl on Instagram her name is like m m
deera or something
like I don't know exactly her her name
exactly but she makes these really sick
low poly but they're also High poly at
the same time these levels and they're
so cool um yeah you just called it Ren
low poly it is guys uh we talked about
doing giant but we'll get giant next
week all right and I know I said that
last week and I know it was a 50/50
between Giant and star it was literally
Ren I held a pole and it was 50/50
between Giant and and Star
Wars oh wow straight 50/50 it was crazy
wow um but yeah guys we'll do low poly
this week I know dearen one of our mods
wanted to do it so we're doing it low
poly you I if I if I join up on another
stream I'll make sure not to have
freaking Vaseline all over my webcam
apparently you're good dude you're good
it's just the webcam filter but even
still it's like Blurry um even I'm
blurry that's not supposed to be I app
appreciate you man thank you so much dud
I appreciate you Clint thanks for having
me on this was a lot of fun thank you
for uh upgrading the textures on the one
wheel thanks to Reed late night renders
for actually modeling it he did a really
good job just to get it here uh the only
thing I've done so far is animate this
thing climbing a curb it looks really
good thank you yeah absolutely I'm
excited to incorporate your textures and
get a sweet render yeah I'll send it
over right here after the stream but um
guys thank you you for joining thanks
for sticking around thanks for all the
super chats um and uh yeah definitely
participate in this week's weekly
challenge low poly is the prompt join
the Discord it's in the description down
below I'll see you guys next week I'll
see you on the Discord throughout the
week and uh until then peace out y'all
oh I'll be on the Discord too now yes
yes all right guys peace out
later
thanks
[Music]
he
a